calling all non-americans out there
maybe some Americans remember when we
did a tour I do we did a tour all across
America last year and a lot of you guys
especially outside of America are like
damn it I wish I could have seen it too
I wish I was in America hell there might
have been some Americans who missed out
on it well lucky you we are releasing
one of our shows just for you yes we are
releasing one of our show
grab some of the merch that we sold onto
it that is all going to be available for
a very limited time with one or two new
pieces this is your last chance to get
tour merch guys so if you'd like to
check it out because again it is limited
access so get in quick click the link
down in the description below to get
your tickets now it's only available for
a limited time so don't waste it they
get you to go on your knees and then you
have to make baby noises I walked at the
club here for a while it's allowed on
YouTube I watched up star dressed up as
Violet from Violet evergard and get DP'd
that's a thing
you just what
welcome back to another episode of trash
taste I'm here with the boy's usual gun
and Joey and today joining us is uh
saikuno welcome yes welcome
to get close to the mic as well this mic
is yeah
I have one of these it's um
so like uh do you wanna we get this like
comment all the time just in case you
know do you want to explain who you are
what you do kind of like what you're
known for yeah self-insurance oh man
what am I know I I play video games yeah
that's
that's most of it yeah I mean you just
kind of explain explain every twitch
stream out there right yeah well not all
of them a lot of them don't play video
games
I try to play some but I don't play a
lot of smart options I should variety
streamer of the year right here this is
probably age poorly are you coming to
the award I am yeah I'll be there well
this this episode will be out way after
this all happened but I am going so
hopefully hopefully it's not pulling
this is going to be poorly do your
victory speech now
do you have victory speech now yeah okay
exact same as you would do it if you had
just won and then when you actually do
it in real life they'll be like oh my
God I'm not gonna win there's there's no
no shot I'm gonna win
do a victory speech and then immediately
afterwards do a speech of like you know
what I didn't win but yeah and the
editor was not the one that's correct
the editor will put the wrong one
I don't know I don't think about a
speech I don't what a speech no I don't
think I'll work for you though you could
just watch it and just be like thanks
yeah well hopefully the one vote is the
you know the Cheeto in the door it's
like yeah I actually didn't like lock
click the vote oh but I did I pulled it
I did I pulled it up on stream and went
through and said this is who I would
vote for and then I did why didn't you
lock it in well I'm on incogn it's
connect the votes are connected to your
Google accounts oh okay I'm on Incognito
because I don't want to leak something
yeah
um so I was like yeah I would vote for
this guy and then I I didn't well thank
you I appreciate it yeah so yeah you
didn't even get the one vote
you'll still win you don't need it it's
because you don't need it every vote
counts man I can't go away for the
results come out and he lost by one
one vote everyone it was tied absolutely
yeah I was I was just happy to be
nominated I didn't expect that so I was
pretty happy with that you're here for
the anime Awards right because you're
you're presenting an award at the anime
Awards Crunchyroll anime Awards how did
it go because it's it's happened
which will be out by the time this is
already out I think I'm presenting the
last one
oh I don't know if that's I actually
don't know the exact one they told me it
was the last one I think okay this will
be really awkward if it's not the last
one cut this out if it's not the last
one but that's what they told me what
plans changed yeah are you a big anime
fan in general
I think I might have watched more anime
than you actually but oh is that a
challenge
this year probably right I don't know
about Joe I will say I talked to him
about one piece okay and he hasn't seen
much one piece it's super long you could
watch like a hundred anime in the time I
had in one piece more than I am I'm
sorry I am okay
he can compete with gone yeah all right
you're the anime guy yeah that's your
thing yeah not anymore though
what oh right Connor was telling me this
podcast just doesn't talk about anime we
don't know actually I'm glad you're on
here because anytime we actually talk
about anime is when we have guests on
yeah as an excuse to talk about anime
okay yeah yeah you're absolutely are you
generally unfamiliar with the podcast
have you ever seen any of this I've seen
like this is I've never seen a full
episode I mean that's a lot but I've
seen like clips from it okay yeah yeah I
mean it's long I get it we talk about
poop a lot and um why is that is that
it's just a guy thing yeah because
they're just lights man you don't poop
well I I just don't talk about I it's
just like there's a guy thing I I
thought it was a guy thing you thought
you want to like figure out the way you
do it is different like if you do
something you know what I do like a lot
the toilets with the button I've never
seen until I came to Japan they have the
button that opens it like lifts up the
the seat for you yeah yeah yeah I feel
like I'm gonna go back and just not be
used to it because like now I go to the
bathroom and I'm like Boop and it just
opens and then you can close it before
you flush which I'm too lazy to do back
at home there's also the ones where if
you in some fancy hotels in Japan you
open the bathroom door oh wait that does
that too it's a little creepy actually
it feels like the toilet's trying to
speak to me it's like yeah it's like
come on in yeah there's there's a few
things that are automatic here in Japan
that I've gotten used to like tax see
doors here close automatically like the
test driver will close the door for you
even the regular like there's the ones
that slide right yeah yeah that makes
sense to me I got in I think on the way
here I got like a Camry or something
right that was also automatic yeah I
didn't know Camry's even had that option
is that like custom-made I think it's a
custom thing yeah you can see the
hydraulic thing yeah my sister drives a
Camry and that was not an option when
she bought it so I don't think that's
next time your sister picks you up
you're just gonna be standing in front
of the door it's like yeah
well yours doesn't open huh like every
time I go back to the US and the UK I'll
I always have this one awkward taxi ride
the first time I come back from Japan I
walk out the taxi and I just walk away
and I don't shut the door yeah and they
have to like call me back
excuse me can you shut the door please I
was like oh yes I'm back uh I'm back in
my home country now yeah living in the
20th century yeah but you know some
toilets also they you know in fancy ones
they'll have the ones that the cover
opens and also the ones where you walk
away and it'll flush for you oh yeah one
does that too but I like the manual
control of it yeah I push the flush
button I will say there's two there's
one for peeing and we're pooping yeah I
don't know how to read Japanese so I've
been pushing both at the same time no
matter what I'm doing and hoping it does
the right thing have you have you
encountered a toilet in a bar where it's
you know it's a male or female but it's
in kanji so no I have not okay okay I
haven't been in any bars or anything
I've just been like so my day has been
um wake up yep uh sneak up to steal some
sandwiches from the fridge that Hassan
usually buys and leaves in there right I
hear him streaming and he usually
doesn't notice because he's he's
streaming yeah and then I get ready and
then we go IRL stream and we're so tired
by like 3 P.M we just we just go home
and sleep and then I wake up at like 3
A.M randomly try to go back to bed yeah
watch some Japanese tick tocks get
really weird ads that I think it's
because they know I'm in Japan right
yeah yeah and Japanese ads are so
strange I don't know what they're trying
to sell me like by the end of it I'm
like I don't know what he was trying to
sell me that guy looked crazy though
Japanese Tick Tock is very horny as well
oh it's so horny a lot of I I haven't
seen that is what do you see on it I
I've when I made a new account the first
10 Scrolls were just women dancing yeah
I was like this is interesting yeah I
was like did you saw it was a male and
she did this that's [__] up it's like
yeah I didn't know that that's exactly
what he wanted yeah how did it go how
did it know now I think I've tailored it
to be uh a lot of my videos uh uh
Vietnamese people argue with police in
Japan that's used to be a lot of my Tick
Tock seriously so obscure did you get
this as well no I know it's a problem
and no I don't get it but yeah that
needs a thing yeah I've never seen why
Vietnamese people I don't know why I
think the police have like uh they got
something against them are they speaking
Japanese to them like when they yeah
yeah yeah but with a very like uh
Vietnamese accent right it's very like
strong Vietnamese sounds aggressive yeah
I I I'm not sure I don't know exactly
well it's a very tonal language yeah so
yeah Vietnamese so I feel like it's
sometimes very aggressive oh yeah can
you speak Vietnamese or
okay so someone if you can say some food
names like foe yeah you can't really
speak it isn't a pho yes I was trying to
see if anyone corrected yeah
I got my v card yeah yeah I guess I
guess they argue with the police a lot
here I don't know why uh but I'm
southeast Asia I have a lot dude I'll
just be scrolling through and I'll just
be standoff have to stand off of them
just shouting at each other because I
don't know why there's so many it's a
it's a big big problem
specifically Vietnamese is it
specifically Vietnamese okay because
they hire a lot of Labor from that point
oh okay okay all right right yeah
there's loads of videos people screaming
in apartment complexes at like 2 A.M
arguing with each other and someone just
filming it it's really weird suggestions
if you tailor it and you have to do any
of that yeah I guess you have to like
you've just skipped past everything that
is even remotely like I guess sexy and
then the moment you get to someone
fighting you've stop and watch it and
then it'll slowly start figuring out
what you like oh you're gonna like you
let me out yeah yeah so you have two
evils either sexy Tick Tock or random
Vietnamese people arguing with uh world
star Japan Edition I mean it's
interesting because you never get to see
this side I haven't seen that at all
everyone seems so polite yeah yeah yeah
almost too polite I went on the train a
few times yeah and they're just everyone
just does their own thing on their
phones yeah yeah it's like the quietest
train ride in the world yeah it's a
little too quiet like I mean have you
guys been to the Bay like San Francisco
has this thing called the BART yeah it's
not as nice definitely not as clean it
smells like pee and when it rains it
smells like Omega p and if that's a real
thing
so like it's I feel like here it's quiet
everyone does their own thing you can
actually sit in the seats which is which
is nice so well that depends on what
train you'll take yeah sometimes it can
get a bit too busy well there is nowhere
to sit or nowhere I haven't run into
that yet maybe I've gone through you've
been going at non-peak times yeah you
also mentioned this is your first time
ever outside of the U.S yeah yeah it was
crazy to me damn it's crazy it's
definitely crazy it's been a long
journey how was your first I guess
international flight uh it was delayed
by like nine hours which was absolutely
terrible uh I think we got here like
four or five a.m Jesus so that was that
was crazy how's the airport experience
coming into a new country
um it was pretty pretty okay I mean I
mean yeah I feel like you got the best
though because like Japanese immigration
is like yeah
I was like slightly worried and then
like a lot of it's electronic really
nice yeah yeah we filled out this thing
on the phone and then you just scan your
code and then you just you're done in
yeah yeah you got you got the nice
version like during last year especially
we had like 10 steps we needed to go we
could even like get on the plane like
yeah yeah and the regulations were so
much more strict than going out going to
every other country so you actually got
in at a nice time I I've heard I've yeah
I heard that every time you've come back
into the country you have to fill out
this form to prove you have a vaccine uh
passport but I understand why I have to
do it every single time like I've
already proved it like multiple times
why am I still yeah that's what happened
why do I still have to resubmit it every
single time it's like I'm not gonna like
unvaccinate yeah
like what am I going to do like you know
what I mean yeah
I don't get it why why can I not just
show the same thing every time what I
don't understand right is like is is
especially if you you know if it's
someone who's been traveling in and out
of Japan a lot right like you have the
travel records on your passport yeah so
you can just be like well I imagine
stickers yeah yeah so it's like I got in
back into Japan after I traveled
overseas so obviously I have the vaccine
possible so why can't you just look at
that and they're like oh but we can't
confirm it I'm like there's a little
physical stamp on my possible that
confirms it
all right so you've you've been around
Japan for like a few days now you said
you've tried the different sandwiches
that Hassan's bought have you tried a
lot more combini food as well
um so we were talking about this last
night
you told us that the one we liked the
most was the worst okay what do you
think is the best food I want to say it
um I want you to say it like it like
just in like the type of food or like
that sure sure in terms of like I like
these sandwiches a lot okay especially
because you can just save them oh yeah
yeah you can throw them in the fridge
and they're still good yeah and they're
so inexpensive everything here is
crazily inexpensive I feel like
I think most of the sandwiches including
conversion is like two dollars or
something yeah which is uh less than
like yeah like it's you can't get
anything for that's not not even a
McChicken and McChickens aren't that
good I'm never getting sponsored by it
cut that out
um they're pretty good but they're like
where I live it's like still like three
dollars or so because you uh have you
always been on like West Coast America
like I pretty much lived in California
like my whole life so yeah so you've
been used to high prices your entire
yeah yeah you know you don't miss the
crust of your sandwiches
uh not not really I missed the crusts
yeah Connor doesn't like the bread
what I love no I like the bread oh yeah
oh wait I remember you mentioned it
wasn't like oh Japanese bread sucks
compared to like European bread it's so
bad but then below Japanese bread is
American bread which is like the worst
what exactly is American bread yo Wonder
Bread is awesome is that what American
yeah that's American I've actually never
had that before so what
I don't know how have I had it does
anyone go to the store and buy Wonder
Bread is that well I mean the fact that
they're still selling it I assume so
yeah but like it's the General on the
Shelf Brad that you get in America is
pretty bad yeah like the supermarket
kind of bread yeah I I remember the
first time uh yeah I was uh staying in
Wisconsin for like two months or
something uh and I remember buying a
loaf of bread there and in England I'm
used to you buy a loaf of bread and you
either finish it in a week and if it's
like that's too long yeah yeah I was
like you either finish it yeah that's
that's like the max right you have to
finish it within a week or you're gonna
get mold in it and I remember I
forgotten I bought this bread and I've
looked at it two weeks later clean
nothing and Sydney was like oh yeah um
that's still like totally fine don't
worry about it totally fine it's like
three weeks to a month or something and
you can still at least what the [__]
insane meanwhile in Japan it's like you
buy a loaf of bread it's like you know
within the next 20 minutes yeah
it reminds me of a chair we did a
charity stream we were doing a week-long
charity events one of them was where we
could buy a lot of stuff from small
businesses and shout out to small
business if it's good right right
there's one where it was Jam you jam
with bread right right we had bread that
was I think a month past the best by
date and we just ate it anyways oh my
God this is pretty fine here in America
right you didn't get sick so uh
have you seen that video where it's some
guy took uh like took an extended uh
shot of McDonald's and he left it out
and then the fries were just like
indestructible oh yeah they were here
later yeah they were just immune yeah
they just like a year later they looked
exactly the same and I'm like I I had a
feeling something like this would happen
but seeing it just right in front of my
face yeah it's probably because of all
the oil they use they just like
mummified the fries there's got to be
some more than oil honestly yeah a
little more than oil sure definitely an
oil alone can't do that yeah that's
immortality yeah otherwise we're just
like soak ourselves in McDonald's oil
and just find the secret to immortality
anti-aging yeah
no
McDonald's oil the ancient Egyptians
could have learned tunnels or something
yeah it's just like you know like you
know there's people in Japan that just
lived like 110 or something yeah like
what's your secret and it's like I stay
up late to get the oil from McDonald's I
hate McDonald's every day of my life
that's my secret Jesus yeah what's like
your so since this is your first time
out of the US what's been your first
experiences of just like another culture
um it's cleaner and safer is the
craziest thing yeah like there's like
they just leave their bikes around yeah
three bikes it's crazy because in LA
right if you leave your bike even if you
lock it like you can lock your bike to a
post right and if it's not a good enough
lock or even if it is and it's a nice
bike it'll be gone in like five minutes
usually London's kind of the same yeah
uh I know that you always walk past
bikes where the train is still on but
both wheels are gone yeah all that
happens often yeah and it's like God
damn I think though in the case of Japan
the reason why I mean it's mostly also
just the fact that people just aren't
willing to steal [__] for in general but
I think in case with bikes the reason
why people aren't just going around
breaking locks is because like most
people have their own bikes and also a
lot of the bikes are very interesting to
sell it I think in the states all right
yeah they still if you see a thousand
dollar bike just sitting there that's a
three thousand dollars okay never mind
but also in Japan like a lot of people
yeah a lot of those bikes are like a
hundred dollars yeah very cheap and it's
like is it really worth potentially
going to prison for stealing a tire from
a 100 bike yeah uh I think I mean I I
have an expensive bike and I've I've
left it unlocked well the places
actually try and Hunt someone down here
like oh like in the States you can get
robbed call the police and they'll be
like we'll think about helping you at
some point
be really valuable right yeah yeah even
if it's really valuable I'm not so I
don't know if we should talk some of our
friends Cars got stolen oh yeah well I
sold a lot of eggs I believe
I don't think the police did much yeah
loving on this video said that he called
the police and they were like oh no that
department isn't working today yeah yeah
they just don't care you can literally I
think Miss cars uh he has a pretty
expensive car I don't know the exact
price yeah right they just don't care
they'll be like oh your car's stolen
um we'll think about it and they'll just
hang up or something um well didn't have
to track it himself or something because
I saw you yeah if anyone has seen this
car yeah please like you know please let
us know don't let the police know just
let us so so what had happened from what
I heard was he actually found the car
himself yeah and instead of just trying
to steal it back he was like I'm gonna
call the police and they'll handle it
yeah um so he called the police and was
like hey my car's stolen I guess I found
it uh can you help me get it back yeah
they just never showed up I guess and he
just took it back himself is the story I
heard oh my God so I was like yeah I
feel like I don't know if you told me
they would try and catch a guy for
stealing a bike you're like nah there's
no way right well like if you think
about it is it considered stealing if
you're just taking back something that
someone stole from you oh no I meant
like the the oh the guy who's got the
guys I guess it's also dangerous as well
yeah in the US well I'm not guys want to
steal a car bro who knows what other
crimes uh yeah I don't know in Japan a
lot of them they don't have guns here
there's no guns yeah well that you you
can get guns but you have to it's well
it's like hunting guns and you've
traveled through an extremely long
process and it's like you're gonna get a
license it takes a while but I mean like
uh yeah I mean the police in Japan don't
have a lot going on and they have a lot
of police yeah long you can feel like
how much they need to do yeah because
the government likes giving jobs to
people and so they're just like you just
become a policeman so they have like
tears of policemen on like how useful
they are yeah
um that whole thing though about like
the department being unavailable is
that's why yeah that's crazy could you
imagine if you like broke your arm and
you like hold up a hospital and be like
oh sorry the doctor's just not into it
was really police right I think because
the police are like ah it's not I know
like during the pandemic they were like
if it's if the items stolen is below
this amount the police won't show up
yeah if it was under a thousand dollars
the police won't show off that's crazy
because it's not worth the time to send
the police it's like the opposite in
Japan where police look for any excuse
to do something even if it's like the
most minor distance uh misdemeanor or
something like that they're all like the
entire Army will show well even if it
was spawn they spawn like like in
cyberpunk oh my God like if you're doing
sex tag or something yeah yeah like if
you if you're like you're having a bad
interaction with a cop within five
minutes there'll be 20 more yeah okay
it's like you know you're a trip over
the wrong guy and then you immediately
immediately get five stars in GTA that's
kind of how it is yeah I remember once
I'm kind of like pressed the wrong
button on his intercom which we like he
didn't know at the time like was a
security button that you press in case
someone Something's Happened I was
worried you pressed it when you guys
were messing with the AC your Airbnb oh
wait yeah there was there was a button
where I was like I was trying to turn
the lights on and off and like there are
all the all the buttons are labeled some
of them actually have English a lot of
them just have like you know the letter
or I don't know what it's called like it
can't as a country the characters yeah
yeah and I was like I don't know what
this means trying to figure out which
one turns off and which light and I'm
like oh this one doesn't do anything I
pushed it a few times and I'm like maybe
I should stop pushing it
no police showed up you still don't know
what the button does but it did
something yeah I remember we were around
Connor's place the other day
um and I think uh uh he had a few people
over and uh Rob CD was there yeah and
kind of and someone called the intercom
and uh Conor was like oh can someone
like get that please Rob Rob presses a
button and I was and he was like I don't
know what button I just pressed he takes
his finger off and he we realize it's
the security button yeah and we were
like oh Connor get here now otherwise 10
policemen are about to come here and
then they're just they'll think you're
breaking in they'll be like yeah exactly
well yeah they call you back and they're
like was that an accident and you're
like yes they're like okay yeah say it
as panicked as possible here like yes
yes most Apartments have this and you
pay monthly for it I you don't even get
a choice like I can't be like no I don't
want it like they they force you to pay
for it right and yeah but essentially
it's like a private Army that will show
up yes yeah the second one I think it's
cool yeah yeah they're like the it's
like one company that runs it all in
Japan oh is it a private company it's
private yeah yeah that's interesting
that's interesting um yeah that's scary
I actually I pressed it also my like
first few weeks in Japan I pressed it at
someone else's house and uh I'm like now
I'm just gonna be afraid to push any
button okay okay go to everyone's house
and be like could you turn the lights
okay so so here's the trick uh it'll be
red no other button should be read and
if it is they're absolutely trolling you
and it's not your fault oh like the huge
button itself no no the kanji will be
red everything else should be black or
another color but the kanji one will be
red yeah um and it's normally like a
it's it should be pretty small but for
some reason in this apartment it was
huge and it was it was and it was dead
center and so the thing started ringing
and they weren't there and I pressed it
uh and then I think they called them but
they missed it and I was just waiting
for them to come back and I'm just
chilling in the living room that's scary
and then uh I start seeing like flashing
lights outside I thought oh well you
know someone some idiot it's got a place
called on yeah yeah the idiot was you
and then my friend came back and and
they got a phone call and they were like
why do I have eight missed calls I was
like I don't know I was watching like
Japanese MasterChef or something oh my
God yeah I'm playing TFT and then uh
they get another call and they start
freaking out and I'm like wow that's
wrong and they look out the window and
they're like oh my God I'm like what
they're like eight police cars they're
like yeah all these police cars are here
for us I was like what why because none
of the calls were picked up they're like
this guy's being yeah yeah because no
one had picked up the calls
um so if you do press it not the end of
the world just make sure whoever's there
answers the thing yeah and explains and
then like a whole dude it was like a it
was like a comedy skit slowly they they
knock on the door and open it up and
slowly opening up this door and this
tiny Japanese like apartment foyer area
where like because you know like the
room between Apartments is Tiny yeah you
open it up and there's like eight dudes
in full like SWAT armor oh God we're
just there and then there's just like
like him like a like a movie there's
this tiny dude comes around the corner
like four foot whips out a notebook and
is like well well well oh God what we
got here then huh daijin I see
foreign
took all my information asked me about
my all my employment and everything for
like an hour and then they finally left
me alone even though my friend was like
no I just dude just chill and I was like
that does not sound yeah that's where I
learned the kanji for uh I don't know
what it means but I know not to press
that can't you yeah it's so impressed
what does the kanji say I don't know it
depends it's the same kanji everywhere
maybe which is like emergency yeah it
might be kinky I know what it looks like
if you told me I'm like don't press that
yeah I just won't turn any lights on in
anyone's house
usually the light switches are like one
yeah
don't don't touch the Instagram yeah I
won't touch anything I'll be like this
the one could you turn the light on
please I need to go to the back I think
when I first walked in I didn't turn the
light on that was on purpose right I'm
just kidding I couldn't find the lights
outside I'm used to the light switch
being in the in the bathroom kind of a
weird what if I'm in the bathroom up
there and and you're just like I'm gonna
play a prank on this guy and you just
turn the lights
I can't see anything I'll be there
I've got carpet in my bathroom and the
place we're staying I've got carpet in
the in the toilet I'm not a fan of that
like what if I miss not that I'm going
to but if I am I'm a pisser so are you
yeah do you guys sit when you every now
and then the bidets are so warm oh they
are warm yeah so it's my job to clean
the toilet in my house and I don't want
to do the work oh I only have to clean
it if uh if if it's my toilet so it me
and Cindy have both of our own toilets
yes we just have cleaners come every
once in a while
La lifestyle man
I'm worse one of us yeah he was one of
the real ones it helps I mean I thought
you were relatable yeah a streamers be
like yeah because like you know I've
heard about stream houses sometimes just
being an absolute [__] mess you guys
are alive like most hours of the day I
do think the standards have gone up
really I'm sorry super long but a lot of
my friends have been streaming for a
long time okay they have those gamer
houses yeah they were really really dank
not in a good way yeah yeah I feel like
the standards gone up these days oh okay
people actually taking care of them
every single quote-unquote streamer
house has been the most excessive thing
I've ever seen in my life yeah I do
think it partially just because
streamers make more money than before
maybe and they have more cleaners
they're necessarily cleaner themselves
but they can afford someone and help
them with it yeah and I think like
security over there needs to be so much
tighter as well oh yeah because I guess
like we don't have any fear of being no
not dogs but at least like swatted or
[__] like that you know I would probably
be more difficult too yeah how the [__]
are you gonna tell the Japanese police
to come to my house you know what I mean
it's like all right good luck yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah they're like this is the
address and they look at the address
it's like oh [__]
anybody who knows no no no no this is
not a challenge but it's a nice layer of
added security where you're like all
right you gotta first of all you gotta
translate this address into Japanese and
then you've got to say it and then
you've got to oh yeah which they don't
do [__] well it's another thing about
like a lot of American friends I've like
I have have talked about having their
car broken into and I don't know if you
guys have ever that happens a lot yeah
that's such a weird think to me because
I've never had even in England like my
car getting broken into no yeah have you
no never yeah I just I just like when
when I when I went to America to uh meet
my cousin she was like make sure there
is nothing on the back seats like no
phones yeah don't show off anything nice
yeah you got a nice bag don't put it
there yeah gotta put it in the trunk
maybe even when you're just parking at
the grocery store or something there's
always something I I would even also
recommend just don't leave anything
expensive out yeah because people
definitely just smack the windows
video I had a friend who was living in
San Francisco oh that's at the capital
of car and so she told me one day yeah I
just went to uh went to go to work and
uh I got to my car and uh there was just
a guy in there and there was just a guy
sleeping in there absolutely sleeping
yes sleeping in the car that's crazier
than I've heard of I've robbed I would
have easily believed that yeah that's
crazy maybe he like tried to like you
know hot wire the car and he's just wait
this isn't working
yeah
it's uh absolutely like different kind
of environment for me yeah what do you
think of Japanese food so far because
you must get it quite a lot in
California already right
really really good here
um and it's much less expensive I think
so there's a Japanese curry place I like
in California
um and I think for the curry like
literally just the plate of curry with
Meats like regular plates yeah it's like
20 something dollars what it's pretty
expensive but I like it and there aren't
that many of them so I'm like I get it
sometimes and then here we went to a
place that was literally better and I
think it was seven dollars
oh no it was a different one I don't
even know the name of it actually go go
Curry it's just like a small one oh okay
it's just a local one yeah much better
is seven dollars and they do like you
choose your size it's the same price no
matter what which is crazy yeah I'm
thinking of cocoa yeah yeah a little
extra for something yeah yeah there are
some things where when they say choose
your size most most of the time it's
just the amount of rice that you have
um but if you have like katsu or some
other toppings on it then that comes
like extra but even then it's like not
that much yes compared to 20 bucks
yeah it's a lot nicer yeah yeah Curry's
just like the cheap food here you know
it's yeah
Japanese Curry specifically Japanese
currency I think Indian curry is way
better I think Union Curry is really
good too it depends on the mood better
yeah
both but like it's you know I I have the
cravings for like Japanese Curry
sometimes because it is different right
and it's like not to say one is better
than the other but like it's it's this
uh it's a safe option you know it's the
most inoffensive Curry you could have
out of all like the World Cup it's like
if you took into Korea like how to make
less flavor and less harsh
little more like acceptable for a light
palette even though it's like compared
to other Foods it's still heavy but
compared to other curries I mean I'm
gonna be patriotic for a second Thai
curry [__] oh wait yeah taiku is one
of the best two yeah I feel like I just
like any kind of career who doesn't like
Curry it's so good it's a [__] harder
yeah to have a bad carry yeah exactly
you know in the UK Curry is the national
dish did you know that
is that delicious yeah legit I've never
had UK is it called UK Curry is that
it's uh the national dish of UK is
actually chicken tikka masala I don't
know if you've had that before I have
but how how did that because it's not
from India it's from Scotland yeah it's
from Scotland
I've only had it at Indian places yeah
it's so it's like a Westerner kind of
thing but it was made by like some
people in Scotland yeah wow it's like
the equivalent that's I didn't know that
it's like
I can't tell if you are gonna trick them
into genuinely no it's gonna go to
someone and be like you know chicken
tikka masala's from Scotland and
someone's gonna think
I'm 100 sure it is it's definitely not
Indian it's like the equivalent of
calling uh you know uh sweet and sour
chicken or orange chicken Chinese food
right because right it is kind of based
on Chinese Cantonese dishes but it was
you know that's part of like you know
that specific dish was invented and I
believe America
yeah so you can't get it in most if you
go to China you can't get in most
Chinese places they'll be like what the
hell's sweet and sour chicken yeah most
likely if you go to a pub uh most of
them will give Curry like a little
server if you want so if I want to get
the best chicken Tikko Masala I gotta go
to Scotland no no no no no no no no no
no that's what I thought you were about
to do no no I'm just saying like we it's
just like it's weird how I think Curry
is uh regardless of where you are in the
world everyone [__] loves just soup
and meat kind of combined with starch
yeah with a little bit of either potato
or rice yeah yeah there's some kind of
starch to go with it it's probably one
of my favorite things yeah it's like I
don't think like on the on the tier of
like you know Indian curries chicken
tikka masala is like you know bottom
tier for me you know there are better
carriers you can get you got to try
Hokkaido soup curry that's that's the
[__] yeah how are you with spicy food I
like spicy food yeah okay okay okay
you know I've met enough people that are
just like I like spicy food and then and
then I always have to ask like how spicy
can you go you know I'm trying this
like okay what's is there we've done the
hot ones challenge okay hot ones
challenge that's something you had any
of those hot sauces I think I've had
some of them okay and
I think there's one called the bomb or
something yeah okay that was like the
max level that I wasn't just absolutely
suffering on
um and I think it was the third hottest
in in the set we bought like a yeah okay
okay it's pretty good though that's
pretty good yeah absolute Max but I
still would go less than that if I
wanted to be happy okay but that was the
max where I'm like all right I just
wouldn't eat it unless I'm like doing
some kind of challenge or yeah
um that's the Vietnamese blood in you
man
it's in your bloodline so yeah if you
can handle like spicy food Hokkaido soup
curry they just like load this [__] up
with spices and sometimes you can get it
like really really spicy a little bit
Moder as well if you can't you know if
you can't handle that even mild it's
[__] awesome yeah okay yeah it's just
Curry but soup yeah very udon that's
sort of like
it's similar consistency yeah yeah do
you like udon yeah
is Udon bad I like a good one they like
udon I don't I'm thinking udon's too
thick ramen's way better I think yeah it
doesn't like it thick don't like it
thick yeah interesting have you had a
any Ramen or any other kinds of noodles
aside from mood on we actually okay this
is absolutely wild but we so the first
foods you think of when going to Japan
at least for me it's probably like Curry
Ramen um and sushi sushi yup uh we
haven't had any sushi because Hassan
just doesn't eat seafood yep uh we're
gonna try and go at some point all right
we also haven't gone to any ramen places
because usually when it sounds like
you'll go like later at night or
something or whatever and we've been so
tired that we just haven't done it so
we've been here for only for a few days
right but we just haven't done like two
of the three things I feel like they're
the instant things you think of when you
go right right so yeah I mean in terms
of sushi I don't know I don't know if
this is a hot take or not but I don't
think Sushi is like people have this
idea that they go to the Japan they go
to a local sushi place and it's just
gonna be like God like like nothing
they've ever tasted before but I think
you get a little bit of an improvement
but not as much as a lot of people think
you get I think it depends on the price
point all right like in terms of like
just like regular can be uh like uh
conveyor belt Sushi like I I say there's
like a slight increase like you're
talking about but like if you want like
the the [__] that will change your life
then you need to be paying like
egregious amounts of money for I mean
it's out and even expensive yeah and
even then it's like if you're not that
well versed in sushi you're probably not
going to taste the difference yeah I
have not had like life-changing Sushi
even at some like really really
expensive like you know like Posh Sushi
chains right
um there's a there's a slight increase
but you know in my mind there's only so
many ways you can there's only so many
ways you can present fish uh you know
you can use fish Wasabi rice and vinegar
right and you you can play around with
the ratio but there's only so much you
can do to get that as good as it can
possible crying right now yeah yeah your
work is [__]
and I say this as someone who [__]
loves Sushi the thing I love about
Japanese sushi is that you can get
[__] amazing sushi for a good price
if you want to get sushi outside of
Japan you have to pay like a [__]
well yeah that's where I think Japan
Sushi's at its best is that it's not
that like somehow the fish is magically
better yeah I just think that at a at an
affordable price point that's much
higher quality than what you would get
like it's in the UK you could buy you go
to the supermarket and get a sushi tray
yeah and it was like you'd you'd bite
into the prawn of the shrimp and it
would like bounce back like your teeth
wouldn't bounce it and they'll be like
that aftertaste sometimes yeah and
salmon would be tough yeah and you're
like damn here it's like it doesn't
matter where I get salmon it's like it's
always good yeah even though it's not
even from Japan yeah and I guess if you
compare it to like a lot of like
American restaurants where you can get
sushi there it's like I think the
biggest benefit is that you pay less for
more fish right so it's like the cuts
are bigger and also it's like fresher I
guess if you can like taste the
difference but like I think that's like
the biggest selling point it's like oh I
get this much fish for like half the
price that I can get in the US okay
that's that's pretty life-changing I
feel like everything's just been less
expensive like a clothing especially
compared to California oh you're in
California
it's like um what's it called yeah the
food is cheaper the clothing even is I
think uh March bought a jacket right a
pretty nice jacket and it was like
I think it was like almost 30 off
basically just because of the conversion
rate right which is crazy I was like I
can't believe I feel like I should buy
everything I can everything's basically
on sale just just purely because yeah
it's like really really bad for Japan
right now which is great if you're
coming to visit uh as a foreigner yeah
because you everything's on discount
like 30 or something like that like it's
0.7 for every uh like around 0.7 I mean
yeah yeah it used to be a lot more
um but yeah since Japan closed off its
country for so long the kind of the
conversion rate just oh that's why
foreigners love Japan right it makes
them feel way more richer yeah they used
to be closer a lot closer it used to be
like 100 yen was nearly a dollar yeah
yeah um and it's way easier to convert
stuff but now it's like I don't [__]
uh use a lot of cash here uh they do
yeah yeah and I my wallet doesn't have a
coin oh I have a coin purse and I just
don't know what to do with the coins
I've been I've been giving all my coins
to March because I'm like I don't know
what I can't just keep all these coins
in my pocket so right I'm like here
here's all the coins use them somewhere
um because I I don't know how to hold
all these coins the craziest thing is
when you you have like a certain amount
of coins and I guess there's a hundred
coins right you give them the coin
you're like finally I'm getting rid of
these coins they give you your change
and you get more coins back and I'm like
I'm trying to get rid of the coins but
now I got four coins from my 1 100 coin
yeah and it's crazy because you can buy
stuff for less than a dollar yeah like
in the US it's like you can't buy
anything for a dollar yeah then you go
to the 90 you go to the one dollar store
and they have things that cost more than
a dollar it's crazy went to the one
dollar store and I was like oh this
looks nice it's like twelve dollars I
was like why is it called the one dollar
store I will say there's nothing more
satisfying than paying for like you go
to a combini and you pay for the amount
you that you buy for the exact change
yeah and just getting rid of all that
change I remember like when I first
moved to Japan I was super like worried
and anxious about like holding up a line
and just like getting the perfect change
but but like after a year after a year
of living here I'm like no you can wait
I'm going to get rid of all of the coins
yeah I've literally like Min maxed the
amount of change I get so I get like the
least amount of change every time I go
to the economy I also like that there's
a five dollar coin I think that's nice I
don't want I don't want one dollar bills
that's so much effort and five dollar
bills so it's nice to have all the bills
be like high denominate denominations
denominations yeah yeah uh this is nice
I like that and the coin is feels
powerful
yeah sure today's episode is sponsored
by Honey the easy way to save When
shopping on your iPhone or computer guys
let's be honest we all shop online and
is there a better feeling than finding a
great deal to save you money when you're
shopping online what about when you find
a deal you didn't know existed that's
like finding an extra Fiverr in your
pocket that you forgot you put in there
well thanks to honey you can do that
because manually searching for coupon
codes is a thing of the past honey is
the free shopping tool that scours the
internet for the best promo codes and
applies it to your cards automatically
all right I'm gonna tell you how it
works all right imagine you're shopping
at your favorite site do it do it close
your eyes right now imagine it when
you're at the checkouts the honey button
will appear and all you have to do is
Click apply coupons wait a few seconds
and honey will find the best coupons you
can find for that site and if honey
finds a working coupon your watch as the
prices drop as you can see I'm in my
Thailand office right now and I've had
to reset up my office with all new
equipment and honey saved me 30 on the
new lights I had to buy for this office
honey doesn't just work on desktop it
works on iPhone 2 just activate it on
Safari on your phone and save on the go
if you don't already have honey you can
be straight up missing out on savings am
I getting it you'll be doing yourself a
favor and supporting the show as well so
what are you waiting for get PayPal
honey free at joinhoney.com trashtaste
that's joinhoney.com trash taste thank
you very much to honey for sponsoring
this episode back to the video I'm
curious uh because I only know you from
streaming well like when did you start
streaming and what were you doing before
streaming because I don't know um so I
started streaming just about three years
ago so it's been a pretty quick it's
only been three years I feel like you've
been on the platform forever
um I'm like one of the newer streamers I
guess right I just got lucky I guess and
pretty well in the short time like
because all my friends right like I
think Leslie just hit her eight year
streaming thing I think Lily hit like 10
or 11 years or something
like everyone's been doing stuff for a
long time I've been streaming for like
three years basically right before
covert base oh what were we doing before
streaming before that I was a software
developer
um so oh hell yeah pretty much had a
regular job and everything oh right I
went back to school to try and get a
better job because it was hard to get
promoted right the tech industry is
usually you never get promoted you have
to apply to a different company right
and if you apply with a better degree
you'll get a better job doesn't matter
what you're doing right right
um so did you grow up in LA or grew up
in La went to the Bay Area or School
worked in the Bay Area and then went to
school right um and then
this is kind of weird but I I'm not good
at like making friends kind of thing
um so what I used to do was I would
leave streams on because it felt like
people were talking to me it's really
cringe it's really cringe but um
basically I I would just go to work or I
would just go to school come home and
just play League of Legends yeah that's
what I did back then and then I started
streaming because I watched a lot of
streams right
um because it just felt like you had
someone that was talking to you when you
came here because it was like school I
would talk to classmates but it's not
like we were friends that would hang out
yeah yeah yeah and then you'd come home
and there's just no one to talk to
completely quiet kind of weird right um
so I leave streams on in the background
to just have some noise of someone
talking yeah
um and then I started streaming to like
kind of do the reverse and I was like oh
maybe I'll make some friends yeah yeah
yeah and I made tons of friends so yeah
that worked pretty well like like you
you sound so confident yeah yeah well I
mean so I've played with
yeah yeah
um and then I don't think we've ever
played but I've met you a couple times
yeah yeah yeah and I said hi to you once
yeah we had like a two-second
interaction yeah
um so what do you think is like the best
game to make friends with
um but uh I don't I'm not actually sure
like probably a teamwork maybe right um
but I think the biggest thing is when
you play multiple different games yeah
right um like when it's just someone you
just asked to play a random game yeah
yeah I agree what what was the game for
you in in your case like what was the
one that like Minecraft was the first
one oh really yeah that makes sense yeah
so I'm assuming you guys know OTV right
yeah yes um I was friends with Lily she
invited me to the Minecraft server were
you friends before streaming or uh yeah
yeah oh wow she was actually the one who
told me I should try streaming oh wow
and then she just invited me the
Minecraft server met a lot of people
there and that's pretty much how it
mostly started cause I was gonna say I
was like it seems uh I'm sure anyone
who's watched this has tried streaming
or or being a YouTuber it's like you
know it's really hard to get that
initial kind of growth yeah go from like
one viewer to 100 is like very hard
especially
um yeah
creators it's like impossible where no
one will ever find you exactly yeah yeah
and so how did you go from like one
viewer to 10 or 100 is it purely from
the collabs or I really don't no I just
played games with the people that liked
playing games with me and that's
since I had like a regular job I never
really thought about yeah I didn't
really care right outside this is really
just for fun well did you quit because
yeah I've always been curious did you
quit your job because you're like okay I
actually really enjoy streaming uh this
is a job I want to do or did you just
kind of like hate your job and we're
looking for something new
kind of I I mostly just because
streaming was more fun yeah and just
made more sense and I think I've made
more money streaming anyway so yeah yeah
kind of worked out yeah because I think
we all have a similar experience where
we went to school studied for a certain
subject found out we hated the subject
and uh kind of like uh yeah let's let's
try content creation yeah yeah not used
to my mechanical engineering degree oh
man I'm sorry well you're one day one
day yeah one day one day I'll build like
a table
on streams
then I feel like I'm getting value out
of it
hearing a story even reminds me have you
have you seen Bocce The Rock
um oh that's one of my favorites
recently so I I have to of course you'd
like it I have to confess I haven't
watched the whole thing but okay clips
and I like the clips I've seen that's
like watching like you are kind of like
bocci's final form I think like the end
of like the journey you know start off
with like a lot of like anxiety and just
want to make friends and look at him now
guys look at him now he's on trash days
now yeah yeah in Japan yeah the biggest
success I've made being on trash taste
pods let's go
the name trash taste is that
um so we were kind of uh brainstorming a
lot of different names because we knew
we wanted to make a podcast and we
weren't gonna let Joey name it because
he would name it uh the anime podcast or
something or the podcast don't you have
a podcast called the anime podcast I did
yeah
that's a real it was the anime show but
to be fair I wasn't the one that came up
with that name okay yeah it was the
radio it's the anime guy yeah yeah yeah
yeah so I was like it was I was doing a
radio show in Australia and they wanted
me and my girlfriend to do like an anime
themed podcast and they were like let's
just call it the anime show and I was
like well [__] I don't have any other
ideas so sure let's do that Joe was like
well that was my first suggestion yeah
yeah yeah you read my mind yeah I think
that's good though I think a lot of
people when you're trying to come up
with an idea yeah a lot of content
creators struggle with they plan too
much and don't actually do it because
they're worried about making it perfect
from the start yeah I think it's better
just do it yeah not great just do it
yeah it'll get better exactly exactly
um so we knew that we wanted to kind of
Market ourselves as an anime podcast
initially but also we knew we wanted to
Branch out of anime so we wanted
something that was like ah you thought
about this oh yeah yeah yeah I landed
out yeah uh I mean loud I mean I I
learned my lesson especially because
it's like calling myself the anime man I
was like I've basically just pigeonholed
myself so instead you called yourself
trash yes
it was one of three names that we
narrowed it down to uh one was trash
taste one was Men of culture
I'm glad you didn't go without yeah for
some reason and the last one was The
Salt Room all terrible man oh yeah yeah
trash taste sounds really nice it sounds
better than before all of a sudden yeah
yeah
yeah so we ended up with trash Chase
luck yeah because uh We've we've all
been creating content for quite a long
time so we had learned you know some
people they just go with their first
username that comes up with uh you know
that they come up with cheers
I've had it since I was like 10 years
old it's good yeah I'm just gonna ask
you like where'd that name come from I
just made it up when I was like 10 years
old thought it sounded cool and it still
does I think
do you mind I think I was smarter when I
was 10 than right now I feel like I was
more creative how do you have a better
sense at naming [__] at 10 years old
than I do at age 20. you know I have no
clue but I don't think I could do it
again my first my first username was
Donkey man five but I spelled donkey
incorrectly and it didn't have a y at
the end because I didn't know how to
spell it was Donkey there's a guy who
spelled donkey incorrectly and he's
pretty cool I've heard really donkey oh
yeah yeah nice hilarious guy why did I
take five though why men five like I
surely the donkey man was I don't
[__] there but luckily they didn't
stick with that now people are rambling
they call you donkey man nobody called
me now it would have been a really
different podcast if it was the anime
manager and Donkey man
so I chose Sea Dog which isn't that much
better
at least there's no [__] weird name
uh number in it yeah yeah
numbers are always bad it was bad yeah I
kind of lucked out with my username um
people think oh it's such a cool name
and it's such a unique name and luckily
it was just like a family nickname that
I had growing up and it was my very
first my very first account which was a
Hotmail account uh yes that's showing my
age right now dude your mom came in
clutch with that yeah my mom came in
clutch thank you very much that'd be
nice to inherit usernames actually let's
we should start that like your kid has
to your kid your kid has to inherit your
username online sounds crazy no that
sounds great because then we'll get like
in like what if your kid's not as cool
as you are my name is
[Music]
we can take it so that like after like
five generations it'll start sounding
already [__] weird and [__] up yeah
it's like so son no matter what you do
your nickname will be Boris mcswady uh
that's just the username curse names
would be fun like this should be like a
thing like a government rule yeah yeah
that all usernames username should have
second names as well like surnames like
oh yeah I'm from the gig up bloodline
actually yeah that's what I mean like we
should have it what about those guys
whose usernames are like XX Naruto oh
that's great greatest imagine that
you're shining uh you go to the doctor
like uh yeah sorry it's XX Naruto yeah
oh yes
two people with their hands up like what
it's like wait YouTube
yeah it's like a narusasu 69. do we have
anyone here is that with or without an
underscore I think I've had a bunch of
different shitty names because I could
never decide on what I like I think one
of them was Xbox best CMC as well you're
one of those dudes who would fight the
PS5 and Xbox and be like this one's
better for sure yeah oh God yeah Connor
was definitely it sounds like I was like
a super toxic gamer I was that annoying
like 14 year olds you hear on like Xbox
way back oh God squeaker yeah not a
squeaker competitive
sometimes we've played I feel like you
are a competitive yeah very much so what
was it that I think I saw Ludwig beat
jump King yeah and you're like I'm
beating jump King now yeah yeah I beat
all the jump kings that he beat uh yeah
invested in the game unless it's
competitive unless he's beating
something yeah unless yeah yeah and
you'll just admit to that you'll be like
100 to beat level yeah yeah for sure he
doesn't take the L line down did you
beat his like timer I don't know uh I
think his first attempt but he's he's
definitely done better runs which I I
should his voice changed a little when
he talked about the competitor like yeah
yeah yeah he's like well I think he did
a little better he definitely is still
better than me at it I gotta get better
though but I did some of the maps
quicker than him okay well me and Joey
are just single player games which is
probably why we haven't played anything
together yet yeah we're just like I'm
out there have you played that no
there's a new expansion I've heard
I don't there was the PVP one I didn't
play that person yeah PVP it's boring
well you do that cheese Strat where you
roll around in the spot yeah I heard it
got patched though oh yeah it was just
it's just over so quick and it's kind of
like I imagine how it feels like a duel
in real life yeah where it's like you
just get shots
and then it ends in a split second yeah
yeah you're kind of like well that's not
fun yeah yeah yeah but then I just watch
occasional YouTube videos where someone
owns someone with a 10 000 gigabrange
Strat and then you're like okay that's
fun but it's for a funny video but how
many times did it take you to to get
this to work like this probably took
like thousands I recorded for like 10
hours yeah yeah three seconds yeah
probably yeah yeah no I'm definitely I'm
definitely gonna play Elton ring
sometime I'm that kind of guy
okay one game of the year it did win
okay I'm that guy who whatever you're
that guy yeah no no you're that guy I am
not a good Factor but I'm that guy who I
just only watch or play things when I
feel like it one day I know this like
this happened plenty of times with like
different anime or different movies
where it's always been on my two watch
lists
but uh wait sit you haven't watched it
either you haven't watched it yet I
haven't watched like I kind of know what
happens because it's such a big show oh
yeah I feel like I could recite like so
we'll watch it together yeah which means
we still don't have to watch it yeah
or maybe I don't know he's never gonna
watch he's never gonna oh yeah probably
neither one
just use each other if anyone's like why
haven't you watched it's one of the
greatest I'll be like I promise to watch
it with a friend and yeah
time zones now we both have a good
excuse yeah okay I'm saying this now you
know I'll watch Full Metal Alchemist uh
when it's like you know watch this same
same
in a few days
but like I'll just wake up one day
sometimes and I will just be like feel
like playing or watching this random
movie or game that I haven't like heard
of or remembered from like years ago and
I'll just like Marathon it all in one
day that is exactly what I do sometimes
too yeah um and it's like I just
sometimes I get so hyped for a game that
by the time it comes out I'm just not
hyped for it anymore like oh yeah yeah
that happens so many times yeah like
like it happened with cyberpunk uh I was
so so [__] hyped for cyberpunk then
obviously it came out even even before
like the whole controversy with the bugs
or stuff
um I just you know I was just like well
I'm done I was like I got my hyping too
long and then I didn't even play it and
I'm like okay I don't feel like playing
it and then everything came out
um and then one day I just woke up like
a month ago and I was like I feel like
playing cyberpunk now and I'm just
watching the anime actually yes after
watching the anime that was good yeah I
liked it I watched the anime I was like
I felt like playing cyberpunk Mountain
marathoned it all in a week and I was
like yeah had a good time I'm glad I
waited for all the bugs to get fixed
yeah no that was part of the fun
was it yes it's all broken and [__] and
it was all funny you must have liked
Skyrim or something yeah I have never
played Skyrim I'm more of a competitive
gamer I don't like this game no it was
terrible but it was funny when it broke
yeah so he didn't like the game he liked
that it was I'm kind of glad that it did
have a lot of bugs because it made it
more bearable because at least well you
enjoyed it because you were streaming
bugs made it more bearable well because
it was like you'd be doing this [__]
mission where you're just shooting a guy
for 10 minutes and then he'd stop
floating there were bullet sponges that
was a thing yeah there's so many bullet
sponges so many oh I was in there for
the world and the characters and the
story and yeah
it looked cool like aesthetically yeah I
think cyberpunk is uh as as a non-game
here I think 2077 is highly underrated I
think uh I think CD projekt Red did a
[__] fantastic job building this
world yeah yeah
like I think the unfortunately the best
content in cyberpunk 2077 is the side
missions I think the main story was a
bit cliche a lot of the times but there
were some really [__] interesting
side missions uh which kind of all
skipped so he didn't get the best games
I want to be done there are two there
are two types
you mainly play competitive games those
as well yeah like balance or something
like that yeah you're very competitive
you pretend not to be but you definitely
are I could tell I could sense it it's
like an aura kind of but
I know I know I I know when someone's
competitive it's sort of different like
I don't try to be good because I want to
win okay I want to do weird stuff so
like uh a lot of people see like and
valoran is a good example
um I try to get good enough where I can
do silly plays that look funny right
knifing people is right like it's just
not a thing you normally do yeah I try
to do it because it's funny right so I
waste a lot of time trying to figure out
how to do that better yeah it's not good
at ranking up it's not good for winning
but it's good at uh making good Clips
there's a time where I played against
like a pro player I knifed them like
multiple times and he was losing it it
was really really funny so I'm
competitive in a sense where I want to
be good enough to do funny things but
I'm not competitive because I want to
win the thing right right I feel like I
feel like it was after the Among Us era
where even people who didn't say they
were competitive they started to get
like a competitive side to them because
I I kind of missed the whole um I didn't
miss the Among Us craze I was very very
late to it and I played my first game
like a month after the craze started or
something and I Remember by the time I
started my first game everyone had like
Min maxed everything yeah they were like
okay where were you what uh what room
were you in what challenges were you
doing and I was like I was uh I haven't
even learned the math yeah I think I
played one game with uh toast and toast
have just memorized literally everything
in existence and I was like well this
[__] sucks in our group a lot yeah a
lot of mods a lot of weird stuff to
Spruce it up which made it fun but
definitely to some extent we were just
like we've done everything there was to
have been yeah yeah I had another friend
who lost it uh because I voted him him
out because he was being sweaty and you
know he wasn't there and he lost it he
went like full like light like at the
end of Death Note speech
[Applause]
idiot what are you doing I'm not the
Imposter I'm not sus and then he was
like girl and I was like well I just
kind of just kind of made the game less
fun so bye-bye oh my God that is
probably the biggest insult you give
someone mine because I've got a crazy
question for you guys okay podcast is
called trash taste which I would assume
means bad taste yeah who amongst you
three have the most trash taste oh God
would you say gone oh wow
for me it's kind of important okay so
he's the only one I could trust him
it depends on which category have you
heard of the domestic girlfriend he's
obsessed with this piece of [__] thing
but the title sounds like like a
is is that a good shows it's incredible
can you describe the plot okay how about
let's do that he describes the plot to
me okay and then you describe maybe
Conor describe it first and then we'll
see I'm assuming I already know it
through him so I I can only guess what
it is okay but I know I know roughly
what kind of happens yes I mean just
like wow just guess what you think it's
about I think okay no correct if I'm
wrong this might be funny for you
because I I this is purely what I've I
just picked up your description before
before you say anything
um um do you like vanilla sweet
storylines like sweet romances or do you
want something that's got a little bit
more like in terms of I liked uh like
Toradora was good okay okay
yeah yeah that was a cute one okay so
that's some drama in it this goes a
little bit further yeah so to my memory
and in my memory of nothing I've just
gone mentioning things right uh I think
it's about a story where there's a
teacher but then the teacher becomes the
main character's step sister
and then they they start like getting
freaky
um but then he has a girlfriend I think
already I think and then he's like kind
of figuring out who the [__] between the
teacher who knows knows his stepsister
and his girlfriend he likes his anime he
loves this anime sure this is one of his
favorite he had an interview with the
author a teacher and a student isn't
that like a like Dad well they're Step
Brothers and stepsisters
I feel like it's like you know how it
really sucks yeah well I guess it's kind
of like if I I imagine I'm not
interrupting you I think it sounds like
it's all true well I think it sounds
like it's all true you know what
um the reality is actually worse than
what he said okay
I I know I remember seeing a scene where
he's in the bathroom and she sits on his
face or something in school and this is
a regular like it's not one of those
those like like 18 plus
it's a regular anime okay it could
probably be in the 18. okay
okay anime opens up okay the anime
literally opens up with a uh with the
main character and he's just finished
sleep he's just he's just lost his
virginity he's just finished sleeping
with a girl that he met randomly
literally scene one of them literally
seen one of them he's like he's like a
[__] chat that that girls are just into
him or no no he literally just lost his
virginity
um with how what's is there a story yeah
yeah so he randomly Mets uh a girl at
like a kind of like a karaoke meet up
and the girl was like I feel like losing
my virginity I choose you like a [__]
Pokemon I don't [__] know like she
just woke up that day she was like I
wanna I Wanna Know What It Feels like to
be an adult I guess
yeah yeah yeah so
um so that happens is this the scene
that hooked you in on the anime or what
well honestly I'm gonna be honest yes
because how many how many anime how many
anime have you seen where the characters
are actually like actually have sex or
do something adult or do something more
than just kids first of all I'm going to
say I haven't seen any and I'll also say
I believe there's a different term for
shows like that yeah yeah it's called
hand side yeah okay but but you know you
know you know I will say that okay hey
hey you know adult relationships uh
human relationships go further than just
hand-holding and having one kiss yes I
get that but you know even porn has like
a beginning plot before they start
talking you know like
the point the point is it was shocking
just to see an anime like open up on
that I'm like oh okay they're taking you
like that it was shocking yeah yeah I'm
lucky I was doing something different uh
which this definitely does that sounded
very different from the description
oh and this is one of your favorites
yeah I generally like generally the
manga I think is it's the best way I can
describe it it's like the most trashy
soap opera you can ever imagine like you
know you see scenes of outer context
Indian soap operas or favelas or stuff
like that this is like on that level
okay like drama so the scenes uh that's
how it starts off and then after that
happens he goes to school and we find
out that this person has a crush with
his teacher
um who you know is his teacher is uh uh
like a female teacher or a female
teacher so their step sister uh we'll
get to that we'll get to that so is
there an age difference I I always
imagine like a teacher is like much
older yeah I mean she's like what you
know like late 20s maybe yeah the guy is
16. yeah
like he's a high school student yeah and
that's okay in Japan or or is this oh I
wouldn't say it's okay very very tough
what do you like about this anime yeah
um so so what happens is uh you know he
he's he has a crush on his teacher his
teacher obviously is just like no you
are a child
um but then he comes home one he comes
home and he realizes his dad's like son
we need to have a talk I'm getting
remarried and uh because his father's
divorced and then he Reveals His new
mother uh his new mother-in-law he's
like great I have a mom now that's
awesome but then it's revealed that his
mother-in-law has two daughters and who
are his two daughters one is the girl
that he just slept with and the other is
his teacher
so at first the teacher says no you're
too young yeah and then
um their step-sister he's she becomes a
step sister and now thinks it's okay no
no because that's what it sounded like
maybe I'm misunderstanding yeah yeah so
and so now they become uh and so now
they all of them become one big family
so they're living in one roof and uh
there's a lot of tension in the house
because he's not innocent it feels bad
the way he's describing this sounds
insane
mind you all of that happens in episode
one yeah that's that's episode one okay
um and so the story just kind of evolves
from there from being just this insane
kind of premise of just all three of
them living Under One Roof and just
[__] figuring out feelings and [__]
is this this is one of the anime you
would say gives him like not highly
rated on yeah a terrible show what's one
that would make him say you have bad
taste I don't think well he did say he
did say you have he voted not an anime
my anime tasted the best well even anime
taste
what what do you have bad tasting would
you say uh nothing
don't know what that is um I think
someone brought it up to me and I
thought they were talking about Initial
D because of the car
I I feel like I definitely feel like
you've probably watched more the thing
you just described I've never heard
anything like even similar though okay
it's a very surface anime though yes
because that's like yeah I watched most
of the main stuff right yeah right I
haven't watched too much crazy different
car yeah yeah I mean like the the anime
I described I wouldn't I wouldn't
actually call it good it's more like a
guilty pleasure kind of show to be like
oh my God this is so if you thought it
was actually good I would be judging you
so hard right now but he loves it he
always talks about it yeah because the
guilty pleasure you see I'm passionate
very passionate seemed like he liked it
quite a bit yeah it's it's definitely a
guilty pleasure hopefully the guilty
pleasure ones are the ones who get the
most I couldn't get over this interview
you did with the author and it was like
the most polite thing ever and it's like
so why oh this I I feel like because
um um uh yeah that's how it always is in
Japan that's how it always is especially
when authors always show like timid and
reserved but then like the stuff they
write is like holy [__] yeah I mean I
did that author I did that interview
with the author of uh read over here
like
um it sounds like an esek guy that's my
guilty almost but you like that show
it's kind of no you know oh it's serious
I did have I had um so I had just
finished watching I think uh konosuba
yeah uh research I think it was I
watched those two yeah someone told me I
think Goblin Slayer was also sort of
like similar because they had like
adventures in a party right yeah because
like konosuba had like you know the Mage
the yeah you know stuff like that yeah
it's also like that and I I watched I
started watching the first episode yeah
I was like oh this is like this is aqua
this is like you know because they had
the whole party yeah yeah and then it
was not like that this was not the show
I thought it was like I thought it was
like that they have
okay so we
this is the guy with the best taste and
Anime out of you absolutely he thinks
this is a good anime no no this is
definitely not a good animal it's a
guilty it's a guilty pleasure I think
it's disgusting it starts off it the
main character is the Healer in the
party all right and it's like a standard
party you got your you know you got your
sword uh that's that's interesting
because usually you'd think the main
character is like the Warriors yeah like
the hero right yeah so there's no hero
there's the Mage there's you know the
the the the the the the tank and then
the main character is the Healer but
this party treats this healer like
absolute [__] like they basically treat
him like a slave just like in real video
games just like in real video games the
healer is the slave right yeah and so
it's the the anime starts off and
they're fighting the I guess the final
boss yeah all right the the Demon Lord
or whatever and they get to it and it's
a really like tough battle so much so to
the point where basically the party gets
pretty much wiped out right is it like
Sword Art when you die you die in real
life no no no this is just like a
standard fantasy world yeah right so
it's like they just so they just regular
die yeah yeah
I think that's a video again
Okay so
they're on the you know they have like
maybe one HP left and they're like Hilo
man please you know help us out okay
even though we treated you like [__] and
then he was like now's my time for
revenge and basically what he does so
the main character becomes a bad guy
yeah baby basically becomes like an
antagonist right because it's like
you've treated me like [__] this whole
time and now you're begging for me to
heal you but I'm not gonna do that I've
trained up my healing power so much so
to the point where I've become Ultra
powerful basically and so what he does
is he basically kills his party
and then kills the the Demon Lord gains
his power and learns the ability to
basically go back in time but he regains
his memories
okay so what he does is he's because
he's regained his memories he basically
goes on a quest to basically relive his
life with that party that treated him
like [__] but now he's gonna try and do
the most like horrendous [__] to them
it's some like weird sick power fantasy
already killed them all yeah yeah but
he's gonna kill them again uh kind of
like but yeah because they did some very
disturbing things to him yeah this is
one of those uh you know like those dark
what's the the name for that genre Dark
Fantasy the the ones where it's like an
evil like kind of thing and a lot of
people die
this one feels more not so much a good
story more like in cells like rambling
where did the incel part come from
yeah uh yes a lot of r word
is this this is not on Crunchyroll uh
it was on high dives it's another
streaming platform yeah uh there's too
many streaming platforms
I like the one there's like peacock now
there's a show I wanted to watch no one
uses
I don't know
yeah he was telling me the show is good
yeah the second I saw I was on peacock I
was like I'm never watching it sorry
yeah because all the good TV shows are
on like different platforms there's
Severance that was only on Apple yeah
yeah it's on too many places I was like
what the [__] I haven't got anything
Apple to how am I gonna watch this oh
you don't use apple like anything
nothing Apple oh okay I'm not I'm not a
California boy like you well I got I
actually used to not use that oh my
family would get mad at me because the
text messages were green
that's the thing
I don't know what the difference is just
a different color the words are the same
words that's crazy I don't know what
changes most people I've met in
California all had like apple everything
it's actually like a lot of America it
actually surprised me the percentage of
people that use apple in America versus
the rest of the world because uh yeah
hearing about the blue bubble green
bubble controversy I don't even know
what it what the difference is the same
I think the green one is they have to
like pay per text no no no no it's blue
is for uh iPhone yeah yeah
you can send bigger files you can send
video files as you text yeah
um but they basically they basically
can I call it class segregation where
they're all like um in a filthy [__]
Samsung user you are a [__] green
filthy green yeah yeah that's what my
family did to me and they're like please
get it so our our family group chat is
no longer green that's so dumb like I
don't want to be judged at work I don't
know what the difference is I mean oh my
God yeah so it's basically like a soft
way for apple to make sure that if
everyone is on like one kind of system
then you pressures other people to join
them speaking of things there's a lot of
I there's no Teslas here is that there
is very little very very little I guess
you're in California
and even Las Vegas they're everywhere I
think the reason is because like there
aren't that many like charging stations
in Japan and also a lot of the streets
are just too narrow to drive Tesla steps
also in just a speed limit pan produces
like the most cars in the world and
Toyota runs everything here at Nissan uh
yeah Toyota Suzuki Honda they own it all
yeah uh so they're like we don't want no
you know because if you if you have a
foreign car here it's like a it's like a
seems like a luxury car so if you drive
like a BMW or a Mercedes is like the
yeah if you have a Mercedes in Japan
they love it
yeah they're like the bends yeah like
dude dude is that crazy like that'd be
like where we live I see them a lot yeah
because in like the UK there was never
this like obviously Mercedes was still a
great brand but like it's nowhere near
like revered as much as it is they're
not like oh the bends yeah they're like
oh Mercedes-Benz yeah you're not gonna
be an airline being like oh he's got
step back
yeah I mean even even the car that
Ludwig bought for himself was a was a
little Japanese car wasn't it but that's
considerable margarine in the states I
feel is because it's an old Japanese car
yeah right and that's like the prime
it's like a vintage car right exactly
yeah it's quirky yeah it's different
yeah very quirky I feel like the
Japanese strawberries are so good I mean
it's because you have American ones yeah
like I barely eat fruits and then I came
here and I like every strawberry is good
well sorry
I don't like fruit that much I don't
like fruit either let me eat a a cream
and kiwi and pineapple sauce oh the
whipped cream sandwiches yeah
like Japan needs to stop doing this
that's not fair
do you hear that convenience stores
Connor doesn't like it you should be
shaking yeah fruit sandwich is the
dumbest thing ever I just think they're
so bad oh my God they're so bad I agree
I just fruits should not be sandwiches
no you're not as good as the other ones
for sure yeah just like I just need a
fruitcake at that point yeah or just eat
the fruit why do we have to cover it
with cream on a bread yeah actually I
think that's the fruit just the fruit in
like a little container yeah like the
fruit tasted good so just give me that
like don't give me the [__] yeah sure so
much yeah like if I want to like a kind
of like a something filling with the
fruit it would be cake it wouldn't be
yeah you know like a Shortcake yeah
you're like a Shortcake or something
yeah come on they're going for a scuffed
version of it with like just the bread
like you know what I mean you know I
would prefer like a crisp sandwich to a
fruit sandwich honestly sure not not
that I wouldn't think you know I don't
know crisp sandwich is that like chips
oh yes no chips oh man it's like it took
a second to figure that out yeah it's
like a British delicate oh wait chips
would be fries so not for me though oh
okay where are you from Australia
Australia the surprise uh like thin long
thick ones which are very normal in the
UK yeah you get those more than you get
the thin ones those are those are chips
oh yeah yeah
um but some people refer to french fries
as chips still yeah but it's kind of
like hot chips oh okay hot chips it's
kind of it is a cold chip uh no that
would just be just
okay I'm just curious I mean unless
you've had hot potato chips before which
do you live you live how long have you
guys all lived here like same did you
all move at the same time no yeah yeah
I've lived here like close to half my
life have your life yes like
accumulatively yeah that's a very funny
yes yes it's Japanese it's my first
language it's your first first language
from Australia guy tells me he's from
Australia I'd like to he's super fluent
in Japanese
well why wouldn't you say you're from
Japan then no because I was I was born
in and raised in Australia born and
raised in Australia and they only taught
you Japanese no they taught me English
oh I'm speaking English right oh yeah
yeah it was your first language so I'm
like what well it's like English and
Japanese I have like two first languages
so basically I when I was born my mom
told me Japanese and my dad told me oh
so you're like part Japanese yeah I'm
half Japanese yeah okay I just don't
look it yeah what did you think he was
yeah
you can say anything I've had everything
thrown at me I actually I don't know
yeah what did you think what would you
have said just from looking at me
I I don't know someone's gonna cancel 20
maybe
um I wouldn't have guessed Japanese
yeah maybe some somewhere from Europe I
don't know well European I feel like if
you're a soccer player I'd be like yeah
he's a pretty cool looking soccer player
or football player a football player you
know do you know what I think it is
um it's the bid it is the beard yeah
yeah because okay yeah like uh when I
back when I went back to Thailand uh
this uh this one time it's obviously
like within the time I've been living in
Japan I've grown a beard normally I'm
like completely clean shaven and it's
like my like every single like every
Thai person even my own family members
were just like I've never seen this boy
in my life you Thai you Thai boy who are
you right now oh man yeah I don't know
ideas aren't really a thing in Thailand
I know no they're not it's just no beers
I mean not a lot of Asians can grow
people yeah exactly yeah I grow a little
hair here yeah little hair here and
that's that's it and then like a little
here but like I'll get I'll never get
anything anywhere around like there yeah
yeah right you know the rare breed that
can actually grow yeah I'm The Rare
Breed this car this is like a few days
of growing yeah yeah I remember when we
did a we did a
uh we did a road trip across Japan and
my beard at the end of that road trip
even though it was only five days it
looked like I just emerged from a cave
man holy [__]
yeah like a Hermit man wait was this was
he in the RV thing uh or a different
road trip gone joined at the end this is
a huge refrigerator a different road
trip oh okay yeah we like road tripping
yeah yeah we like traveling it's fun in
Japan yeah yeah yeah yeah driving's fun
in Japan I don't know America is like
mind-numbing you just drive eight hours
there's a lot of grass and cows in
between yeah I think so yeah that's
that's like but that's not much though
right like in Japan there's always
there's always cool stuff to do along
the way yeah
and you're never far away from something
yeah so what other plans you have now
they're here in Japan anything you want
to do or where you feel like we're
actually low on time like yeah we've got
tomorrow and then well tomorrow we
actually have a rehearsal for them oh
that's gonna be a thing so basically
tomorrow can't do much yeah day after is
the award show so yeah I'll be gone then
I'm leaving the next day what's your
enemy of the year if you're presenting
that
um my anime of the year did you wait did
you vote on the anime Awards
and they said come presents an award
will pay for all your stuff and I was
like sure I'll go let me know what day I
gotta show up and girls that was about
it awesome I don't even know how to vote
um but uh I mean well I I will think
it's it's it's cool that like they
didn't make me do a bunch of shout outs
or anything yeah yeah yeah yeah show up
show up good so very nice of them what
would you have voted as your anime of
the year that's so for 2022 yeah I
imagine
um I didn't watch too much anime there
uh okay these boys didn't I'm right
there I watched a fair amount okay let's
all go through and say ours and maybe
it'll change my let's start over over
there
we're going to sway your opinion yeah
I'll go last I'll go Bochy the rock is
not from last year oh technically it is
or maybe spy family is it nominated not
nominated because for some reason
they're like spy families from last year
yeah that's a really good one that I did
watch I guess I'd go with that just
because the goal isn't included yeah I
don't know why only recency buys all
right yeah yeah I think too like because
because I have problems with that a few
years ago but we will include falling
our anime of the Year prediction yeah I
just go for spy family because I uh I
watched it the whole way it's just a
nice wholesome show yeah I didn't finish
it
got bored really yeah yeah this is this
is Connor's game of Brain all right
let's go next when is when is you're
gonna like do assassinating when is that
gonna happen again like it's like she
just became a housewife and she like
actually became a housewife yeah but
that's what people like right no yeah
he's still doing spy [__] why isn't she
being an assassin still it's [__] up
it's called spy family not assassin
family yeah yeah Checkmate atheists
I feel like they had a really cool
character and they just left it they
were like well [__] it I don't know yeah
I should be a housewife man yeah uh my
anime of the year
chainsaw man but it kind of was there
because that last tier too yeah that was
awesome technically yeah technically
yeah it's like I don't think anything
did blew my mind more I honestly kind of
agree with you like like I hate being
that guy who goes for it yeah yeah but
it it kind of It kind of wants to go
it's pretty [__] amazing it was kind
of [__] amazing like I don't know how
to be like no I think God's Gonna whip
out something crazy now I'm just uh made
in this too okay okay okay I haven't
watched me the best too yeah that was
not nominated uh what yeah not many
people watched me in the middle you
wouldn't have gone the votes yeah I
think it's really good too yeah yeah I I
don't think it would get votes it didn't
get nominated I don't know how uh what I
think is going to win the anime Awards
I'm gonna make this prediction now so if
if it's correct by the time oh here's
what we do say like five anime right now
yeah and you'll look like a genius
they'll edit out the wrong ones all
right so just list them off chainsaw man
yeah I know what's going to win it's
attacking Titans gonna win oh
I just like the memes honestly the memes
are the best parts yeah I've seen the
memes and I have Aaron talking to well I
guess I don't want to spoiler but you
know the meme with Aaron talking hold on
a second why do you think it's
underwhelming I think Attack on Titan is
like right at its best right now
um with uh you know without without
spoiling uh like the plot twist that
happened in the previous season and uh
some of the hype [__] that happens
that's [__] we we are definitely not
crazy stuff's happening yeah yeah why do
you think it's I think just the way that
they're I think it's the way they're
releasing it has been really killing
yeah fatigue right I'm dude like I
thought I was so ready for this to be
the final season when I kind of figured
out it wasn't gonna be I was like my
final season final edition part three I
think it is as we've discussed before
with like you know Netflix jail and
stuff like that like how a show releases
is really impactful in terms of my own
enjoyment absolutely and I find that the
way they've been releasing Attack on
Titan and you know not I don't know
whose fault it is or where the blame
should be put but I think it's been
killing the hype for me they're milking
it they're milking it
I don't even know if they're milking it
I don't know if I don't know if it's a
mess of because they change Studio as
well which means like what was that
about so I don't think they're milking
it maybe maybe in terms
yeah maybe in terms of like the release
schedule because it takes a long [__]
time to make Attack on Titans as good as
it is I think it does I wish it is yes
and I think I would prefer them to just
have a more extended break rather than
split up to five million different parts
yeah that's been killing my enjoyment
because it's like it's like the where
did they release the uh the code GEOS
they released a key to the Exile but it
was like this is Way Way Back by the way
like and this was like where I [__]
loved Code Geass and they just kind of
release these parts four Partridge all
over the place it was like they dropped
one they were like it's coming next year
nothing and they just dropped two parts
in one day yeah didn't say anything it's
like what the [__] like Can it can we
get some kind of consistency going on
here like it's like having like the
accurate amount of like enjoyment or
expectation knowing what to come in with
it and what to expect helps so much with
yeah kind of figuring it out like they
should like give you a date yeah or just
tell me when it's actually gonna end
stop calling it The Final Season stop
telling me this [__] and it's [__]
with my expectations they mean this [__]
like [__] Photoshop files is like you
know like I I think I think final edit
yeah this is the real thing the actual
final Edition version 20. I I feel like
to actually enjoy Attack on Titan I need
to wait till it's done and go back and
re-watch all of it again in like one
sitting almost like one kind of just to
get a real good enjoyment this is why I
don't watch anime weekly because I feel
like some in cases like this you just
you enjoy them it just drops yeah I'm
kind of like a marathon kind of guy oh I
want it all in one go and it just it I
and I agree but also I really love the
public discourse that goes on every week
oh shame I love like you know last of us
I love watching people get angry every
week at dumb stuff that doesn't matter
try watching One Piece weekly
um
nothing happened again yeah most weeks
nothing happens but every once in a
while one episode is really really good
yeah
that's when you like times nothing
happens being in the end on that feels
so great like being able to have a
shared experience with thousands of
other people yeah without knowing
anything about each other it's kind of
cool what I do is I just open up Twitter
and if I see one piece trending I'm like
oh wow
wow they actually did the same thing
where you know uh where something big
happened in the last Arc of one piece
and I was like all right it's time to
catch up to one piece I guess yeah yeah
like I don't know there are a lot of
content creators who can do like weekly
one-piece content or weekly like Naruto
content when that was still airing and
I'm like how the [__] do you have enough
to talk there are some content creators
who are stupid
I don't see a lot of uh uh no I think it
was Sasuke fighting dinosaurs uh from
Jurassic Park
yeah yeah did you guys I've heard of
this
I thought it was an edit when I saw it
I'm like this this cannot be legit
and I'm just thinking back to all like
the boruto fans that are like yeah it
gets good later on yeah and then we get
that so the crazy thing is I saw one
week right yeah and I swear this all
right I didn't watch it but I swear the
ark must have gone on for like a month
at least because at first it was one
like Raptor and I was like haha that's
funny it's probably a one-off episode
nothing can happen next week I see more
clips
um Sakura gets attacked by a
brontosaurus and then there's
pterodactyls flying in lightning and I'm
like what is happening now this has gone
crazy and there's there's even once and
where he's like Genji genjutsu doesn't
work on this Raptor and I'm like what on
Earth is happening
I was so confused but I don't know it
could have been an edit I I don't know
no no I'm pretty sure that's just boruto
every time in my life yeah every time I
like watch a clip of borrow so I just
like what what have you done to my boy
what have you done to my boy I just
imagine like Musashi Kishimoto just like
a single tear like goes down
he's like it wasn't worth your money
actually I gave him the right so he
wipes the deal with like a stack of
bills I'm so sad so yeah add more
Raptors
so wait why are they fighting Raptors I
don't know because boruto oh okay okay
sorry I shouldn't ask that was the
definition
crazy that it happens I yeah I mean I
think I I I think Naruto should have
just ended if I'm being honest
um well like a hot day I mean I mean I
feel like if you're gonna make a new
series with Naruto with a big franchise
like Naruto just wait a few years you
know wait wait for the death of the
franchise to kick in before you suddenly
just reboot it into something but I I
feel for for someone like hishimoto and
a series like Naruto it would be almost
impossible to like move on from that
because you know remember he tried he
tried to release Samurai 8 which is that
like other manga that he started I don't
remember
like three volumes because it's like no
one read it everyone was like we just
want more Naruto and it's like I feel
for like an artist like that it's so
hard to like move on from something else
unless the thing you move on from is
like even better than what you were
originally which is tough yeah yeah and
like the only example of like an artist
who's successfully done that it would
probably be like you know going from you
you haksha to Hunter
oh well those are the same dudes it's
the same guy wow yeah they did great
yeah yeah same guys like you was already
amazing and then he was like okay I'm
gonna try and one-up it and he did you
know so Jerry still needs to watch
Hunter yeah I'm saying this is someone
who's never seen hunt Hunter oh okay it
was good yeah one of my favorites yeah
exactly yeah and it's like just yeah and
I feel that's the only way that like
hishimoto will be able to like start a
new series and actually like move on
from Naruto but no more ninjas or I
don't know but then he was like I'll
just do a spin-off of his son yeah
nobody wants that no I I think everyone
wants the sun yeah I think it's actually
a different mangaka so he's only uh he's
like overseeing he's overseeing yeah but
I mean what does oversee mean which
means he's retired with stacks of cats
yeah which means he's on the payroll
chilling out with uh mimosas having a
good time he basically learned from
Toriyama and he's like oh you made how
much off GT yeah it's like I'll do the
same thing yeah yeah he gets in a zoo
meeting and it's just like oh yeah we're
thinking about adding dinosaurs to
Naruto uh is that cool he's like yes
keep going yeah
he's like I don't see why not
Jurassic Park did well yeah exactly
exactly
though they finally announced that it's
it's not going on Hiatus anymore it's
just straight up cancer it's just
straight up Council yeah I was hoping
for something else yeah yeah yeah why
because right now it feels like just
commit to the Hiatus because we've
that's what they've been doing for like
20 years no I'm I'm glad that they just
committed to the fact that we're never
going to see the end of the story
because we we never were even with the
Hiatus but he's coming back last year
like four times I saw that now my hopes
were high he had like two million likes
on a tweet of him just being like am I
command he drew a tree and I got two
millions I was like what the [__]
yeah I think I think it's because
they've finally realized they're just
like it though like tagashi was just
halfing copium when it came to like
coming back he's just like yeah I'm
definitely coming maybe yeah I could do
that yeah
such a good [__] show and he took a
nap and woke up nah never mind yeah he
took a nap woke up when it was six years
later he was like oh [__] okay he's like
all right I can't do it anymore guys
yeah yeah but I'm glad I'm glad it's at
least like I'm glad it's not on Hiatus
because I can like put in my mind okay
this is finished now I can put it away
in my mind but it doesn't have an ending
right it's just stopped yeah well that's
so [__] yeah I mean bizug fans like
first time
blaming berserk uh yeah but it's not the
same yeah
it's a different you know it's a
different author so there's always no
matter what even if it like [__]
slaps there's always going to be that
group of people who are like well is
this the berserk that was going to
happen though you know yeah you know did
you read berserk at all no no sorry it
was good actually well I was telling the
reader of gila being a dark fantasy I
think the best dog fantasy is berserk
like this one would you recommend
someone start with if I've never watched
anything like in that type
berserk is definitely because like
berserk is inspired accountable
I've watched anime but I don't read
manga like ever okay if don't watch
don't watch the Berserk anime
um except the 90s one 90s yeah I like
the 90s the nice one's decent I feel
like if you are ever interested in manga
if you start off with berserk that's
where like the peak of manga is yeah if
you ever were interested in Waiting you
like Elton ring right yeah Elden ring is
like that all that kind of imagery and
the the scale of the monsters and all
that it's all very berserking the
creator of the Soul Series has that his
biggest influence was observed it's it's
I mean I have seen the guy with the big
sword which does remind me yeah which is
yeah
the style looks like it yeah
um yeah it was one of my favorites I
think they actually have his sword in
the game or a sword that looks very yeah
you can dual wield them as well oh [__]
yeah
you don't get too much benefit from dual
wielding the big you don't get that much
in fact it's actually worse but it looks
cool it looks bad look it's a statement
at that point you know what would you
say then is like your like all-time
favorite anime that you've seen like if
you had to pick one oh man that's I know
that's a hard question difficult
um and I'm I'm sort of the dude so I
will say my choice wouldn't be based on
what I objectively think is the best
anime I don't know the answer for that
either yeah it would pretty much just be
the one I grew up with right it has the
best memories right yeah so it'd
probably be like Naruto or one piece
because those are the first ones I watch
okay so it's kind of like I don't know
if they're the best objective anime ever
but well which fan base you will ask
yeah oh yeah I mean I I still think you
know I still think they're both great
shows but one piece especially is that's
still going strong in fact one piece is
going stronger than ever after what 20
years yeah yeah wano was [__] insane
um
seems so long yeah I'm right there with
you man so long yeah even Joey needs to
catch you yeah but yeah my one-piece
video is just going to be a business
class flight review at this point
because I am only reading it on flights
oh really that's actually what a lot of
people yeah because I've got a lot of
stuff because I just stick a GoPro and I
just [__] read it and then I'm like
all right cool this video is going to
take like 12 years and it's just all
gonna be flights yeah yeah I don't know
what I don't know why you are doing it
all in one video you could easily like
split that up into seven I just want to
make like just one giant video because
like one piece fans are like kind of
like Jojo fans and that yeah they like
they want anything like as soon as you
finish an arc they're like what did you
think of that Arc tell me tell me
everything what is the rank I need to
know yeah I know I just want to go
through it then I'll make a bunch of One
Piece content afterwards but I want to
make one giant one-piece video I'm like
that is it don't just go to that video
If you ever wanted me to wear one piece
yeah I thought about doing that for the
JoJo video as well I was like yeah it's
just easy if I just do it all in one big
video yeah I think so too yeah well look
look forward to Connor's video here in
about 10 years
I think it'll come out
either
late this year or early next year okay
it's going to take forever because I'm
you heard it here again
for like seven months okay let's get an
update where are you where are you at
right now I'm not halfway nearly halfway
halfway you're nearly halfway uh Arc
which are Thriller bars okay okay okay
that one wasn't my favorite art person
it was all right it was it was all right
it was all right it wasn't my favorite
because I don't want to say too much
yeah well let's I don't want to hear any
further I'm trying my best not to talk
about it yeah
but uh I mean I'm enjoying it I'll just
say that much okay that's good I'll see
you for the video yeah we'll save it
before open up this video like Jesus
Christ the second coming of Christ
himself another year another year of
hyping it up and nothing I'm saying I'm
not going to talk about it and then it's
gonna come out yeah this year well maybe
next year we'll see how this way he's
backpedaling yeah just don't like see me
read that [__] yeah yeah sorry guys
we're delaying the video one week yeah
I'm sorry guys so did you watch all of
Naruto then or did you read that at some
point so I watched up to most of
Shippuden yeah and that was most of it
okay so was it like the did you get to
the fourth ninja war rock at all because
that's when I started
um I don't know if I did because so I
watched a lot when I was like really
really young and I'd go to uh so the
anime wasn't so big back then yeah what
would happen is you would buy ripped
burned CDs from the local scuffed DVD
store here
my uncle owned the store
um and that's where I would get it from
and I would get like Naruto episode one
to ten Super Late by the way like you
wouldn't see it weekly yeah I mean I
just watched the original Naruto way
back in the day oh yeah that's you know
it's very similar to what how I first
started Naruto actually I bought my
first ever first purchased it was with
anime was uh on eBay and I thought I was
getting an official DVD oh it was just
Birds DVDs
with a sharpie yes
one to ten yeah
um it was just a CD the folder with
burnt CDs on it and that's how I got
that's how I go into anime I'd rather
that than subscribe to Peacock streaming
I'll say that much the same same I
rather have them like sub espanol part
eight wait I used to watch that on
YouTube because they for some reason
they wouldn't get mad at the Spanish
subbed one for some reason I don't know
why those are the only ones that existed
the YouTube like yeah I'll survive how
could you read the subs
um you kind of couldn't but you would
sometimes the the they would have the
added captions
or someone in the comments
but I did take Spanish in high school so
I could sort of understand some okay but
a lot of times it was just like just see
what happens and you can kind of tell
from the pictures there's a lot of
Spanish in California a lot of Spanish
like you just see Spanish yeah Spanish
TV it's quite common like um at least in
La yeah every school would be like well
at least my school would be like you
have to learn a foreign language they
recommend Spanish because there's a lot
of Spanish right right that makes sense
that makes sense I mean for us it was
French mostly I took Spanish in high
school as well though I've forgotten all
of it so please please use uh useless to
me right now yeah yeah did you have to
do anything in uh Australian like what's
what's on the Australian curriculum uh
so it depends on the score but my score
only offered one language and it was
Japanese well that's awful and I'm like
well um
yeah I literally sounded so strange
really yes it was only Japanese and it's
like I mean again it depends on the
school because like a lot of like the
other schools in the area were offering
like you know the standard like Spanish
and French and you know all that kind of
stuff yeah but for some reason our
school was like only Japanese
and I was like uh okay so I would just
sit in the back of the class and you
know they'd be teaching them like
standard like you know are you or only
hearing on and stuff and it's like I was
just sitting I was just sitting in the
back of the classroom made you turn up
to that I had to turn up because it was
it was in year eight it was a compulsory
subject that speaks better than the
teacher
I think I did yeah I literally had
moments where the teacher would be
teaching me something uh we're teaching
the class something and then just every
now and they'll be like that was correct
right Joey and I'm like yeah yeah
well I'm getting paid for this right
you're like yes goes back to playing
like Final Fantasy yeah I was just
playing on my DS the whole time I'm like
it was great you guys got another
recording today yep yeah it was gonna be
absolutely Juiced packed up um because
you got someone coming soon right yeah
yeah yeah yeah I think well that sounds
almost here I think yeah yeah Sons
if he ended his stream he's on the way
here okay an absolute workaholic there's
no chance he's dawdling around somewhere
okay kind of a little worrying but you
know some streamers just like that
they've just mined he gets to where he
is by working like that yeah I respect I
couldn't I couldn't imagine
yeah that's why I could never be a
twitch streamer oh that's I went to a
YouTube uh Summit thing right that I was
invited to because you know YouTube
contracted me yeah and like I I think we
were the only few you know streaming is
not huge on YouTube yeah compared to
Twitch
um so like I went there and I noticed
the biggest difference between talking
to streamers and YouTubers they actually
take breaks like I feel like for me
um I'm taking like eight days off
streaming yeah absolutely insane like
nobody does that yeah um it's just crazy
to do that usually I'll take one day off
maybe yeah um maybe one day off a week
is that why you haven't is this why this
is the first time you've traveled
outside the country
um well that's just because I didn't
have a passport and I never found a
reason to oh yeah I feel like streamers
don't take many days off yeah especially
you can't you are you are like locked in
that grind because I mean I've like
tried you know several parts to like
tried streaming more and then I realized
if I just take like one week break your
viewership just halves yeah like yeah
it's not good for that um and you lose a
lot of your subs that's a lot of your
Revenue yeah so it's just bad off
viewership down Revenue down everything
down yeah um and also you just know
you're not because like I know a lot of
streamers when I talk to them they're
like when I have the stream on money's
going I'm making money yeah yeah so it's
very easy to be like why am I not doing
that why am I not monetizing this one
yeah like I can turn this on and yeah I
get paid and I got bills to pay
everything yeah so I feel like it's very
easy for streamers to just be like oh I
could do that today yeah and make a
certain amount of money like I know some
people who uh will be like I make this
amount of money every day yeah and if
they take a day off they'll be like I
just lost some amount of of money like
and they'll be and they'll just feel bad
about it and it'll bother them I think
it's hard to like get away from the
mindset it's a I find it's a really
unhealthy mindset and I feel like that's
why yes what the man is outside Hassan's
outside yeah okay
um and I feel like that's why it's so
easy just to get caught in like stream
of burnout I feel like is way more
prevalent than extremely calm yeah
because even taking a day off you feel
super a lot of YouTubers that I met
there like I make a video every few
months and then the rest of the time I'm
doing whatever and you're like oh wow
that's that's pretty nice yeah yeah like
I've gone I've gone down to like a video
or at most two videos like a month and
I'm like yeah it's pretty good yeah hey
have you guys met Michael before
um yeah yeah he'll make a video maybe
once once a year yeah he's doing great
but every video is a [__] Banger man
you know and his views very hard on yeah
every every time he uploads a video
reviews are always banging is always a
video you know really respect him as a
content creator he's one of the content
creators I watch every video he makes
yeah yeah which is a low effort
commitment because it's once a year
it's like Christmas yeah exactly I love
his videos though for sure yeah yeah
what'd you do on holiday
you take a break what'd you do you don't
take breaks yeah he's always he's always
live yeah that's that's what I'm asking
I mean I'm not as bad as a zon yeah say
that
um I do think moving to YouTube helped a
lot right now I get paid you know like
can't say too much obviously yeah yeah
now I get paid no matter what like I'll
make enough where I don't have to be
like I'm not streaming this day I'm not
making this money that I might I might
need for something right
um so I think moving to YouTube let me
do a lot of things where I can be like I
don't have to stream this day I still
got to do it like you still don't feel
it but it's like did you count this is a
holiday that's all I like to but my
body's telling me otherwise because
we've been getting up at like 6 a.m
We Come Back you saw us at that dinner
Ray was like falling asleep yeah yeah
like Hassan's still kind of alive
because he was hopped up on coffee and
stuff like the rest of us are like guys
yeah I can't wait to go back after
eating yeah raise like if I drink a sip
of alcohol I'm gonna KO like I'm so
tired
um it was um yeah so it's like sort of
yeah I mean it definitely was fun I
enjoyed it do you want to travel more at
all like I want to come back to Japan
actually I know there's so much we
didn't get to do oh yeah yeah you'll
have such a short time you should
definitely come back and try it and we
missed our first day because of the
delays right right
exactly like I feel like you've spent
all the time in Tokyo and rightly so
there's enough to do to like put your
time in just purely Tokyo but there's so
much of Japan that's interesting as well
yeah and you know there's stuff to do
huh compared to like La there's stuff to
do oh yeah go around and do things all
there's stuff to do as well in like
close proximity to everything yeah you
can just go to and I'm like wow I could
like go somewhere new every week yeah if
you lived here for example yeah you
could work and stuff and then every
weekend or something I don't know maybe
not weekends usually so this is a pro
pro content creator tip yeah just don't
go out on the weekends because that's
when all the regular people go yeah
always go out on like a week day when
you're like on a Monday it's my first
week doing content creation yeah you
wouldn't believe it but a lot of people
like um are just we were booking a
vacation in uh Big Bear yeah uh recently
we just got it a weekend instinctively
because that's normally what you do yeah
there's there's so much traffic uh I
didn't even get to ski because it was
packed and I was like guys why did we
come here what a weekend
just showed up at any time like on a
Monday at midnight and like absolutely
had no one to you know like you know be
crowded with I think the only thing that
happens when you I guess uh maybe become
a I noticed when you become a big
influencer or whatever you want to call
it
um you still kind of do have this weird
notion of weekends are kind of a bit
more free because more often not maybe
your agent is kind of trying to contact
you throughout the week and you say hey
I got this deal you should oh man let me
tell you I'm the least uh I believe that
I believe it all my friends have like
assistance they have like teams I'm like
I'm just the dude who just plays games
so I'm very not uh not very professional
this is so funny because when I was
talking to YouTube about them buying me
yeah um I was like
and then I was just like
um yeah I don't really have they're like
so do you have any crazy plans coming up
and I'm like no I'm probably just gonna
keep playing games and they're like okay
okay uh do you want any help doing
things and I'm like no I was just gonna
play some more Among Us in like some
other games and they're like okay do you
what what kind of content do you want to
make and I was like I'm just gonna play
games with my friends and then I don't
know if that hurt my negotiation at all
but I'm definitely like not as you know
professional I don't know I'm not like a
real content creator I just you just go
with the floor right yeah I kind of just
played games maybe some would argue that
makes you even a real content creator
you are so nice Connor I don't know
about that just wait we gotta we gotta
have more food and drinks
I'm being nice now that always says nice
things about you
that's not as true that's true she does
everybody does actually yeah I've
definitely been enjoying my weekends
more I've had to learn as a content
creator how to enjoy my weekends uh no
it's it's no it's true genuinely when
you when you fast when you first start
you're like I can work any day and then
take a break any day but the point is I
feel still like it feels weird taking
breaks on weekdays you know because
everyone else is grinding and I you just
feel like I could be I could be working
right now because everyone else is
working you see like the messages from
your agency and people are still in the
office and you just like doesn't feel
like a proper break but especially like
you know you know making friends who
aren't content creators as well
especially and hang out with them you
I've learned to appreciate my weekends
more because it feels like nobody's
working now so yeah I don't feel guilty
for not working as well even just seeing
messages about work and sometimes drag
you back into that kind of work mindset
so yeah that kind of ruins if you had a
good vibe going on you're like
[Music]
the biggest thing that starts me from
Ultra streaming
um is just my voice gets tired so I
typically stream six to eight hours
every day it's a lot of talking it's a
lot of talking so at some point like I
physically will like there's a time
where I just lost my voice and like I
was like I've just been talking too much
yeah I think it's like um that's the way
you draw the line yeah like when you
just can't and I'll still be playing the
same game off stream I just can't talk
um I feel like it's like Disneyland yeah
so do you have games that you play on
stream or games you play offstream or is
it always the same game
um usually the same actually sometimes
there's a few games I just play off
stream because like yeah uh there's all
fit for stream or something yeah like if
I if I can't talk while playing like if
I have to focus a lot yeah yeah I feel
bad if I'm not talking because it's like
yeah that's the point of the stream kind
of yeah yeah for sure so it does depend
on on the game
you're more truer gamer than Connor is
man
I mean I just play TFT off stream
too because there's no no one wants to
watch you play TFT I just don't know
what to talk about I can't be like yo
guys I'm rolling the best you know like
it's hard to it's hard to like be
excited nothing crazy crazy yeah it's
also like a lot of a lot of information
uh being taken in if you don't know it
and it makes no sense and a lot of
backseating so much backseating which
makes it you know a struggle a bit of a
struggle yeah yeah there's some games
that are just awful at back seating yeah
trash is bad oh my God
might you know like reduced by 200
messages so it's 200 points just by
streaming it unironically uh I believe
that was 100 ELO chess player because I
was well first of all I only did the
bong Cloud because I thought it was
funny
throw that in with the fact I'm actually
just bad at the game and it was an
absolute disaster
um Conor's pretty good I know it's gone
because I've lost yeah he wants to gone
yeah like once or I mean it matters the
one time
we had a tournament and I lost so it's a
shame I try not to relive but it's okay
he uh wanted the chess boxing I did be
loving that was fun laughing were you
ready for that you looked kind of
surprised uh well I didn't know until
like three hours before Oh I always
slapped you oh you maybe thought he
wasn't gonna like actually no no I I
don't know I think I knew it was gonna
happen I just I guess you don't know how
can you prepare for a slap if you were
hitting him first would you have gone
easy uh uh I don't know like I
definitely would have if I was if I was
there and I was against my friend I'd be
like no we're not doing this for real
right guys I'd be like oh there you go
and then I feel like we think the same
on a lot of things so I kind of just
knew telepathically with him I was like
all right I know how hard we're going uh
very hard it wasn't that hard I think I
have a video that is out right now where
I got slapped by muscle girls and they
definitely went way harder probably
buffer than Ludwig I bet I'm most
certainly buffer than London there's
like a muscle girl yeah is that one yeah
yeah 18 of them beat me up you got what
would they just line up 18 of them just
walk yeah 18 of them yeah yeah it's got
a dog pound I did how did you come
across this like did you just walked in
you're like excuse me could you all slap
me like oh you can pay for that normally
yeah pay them to sleep all I did is an
interesting place guys are into that
yeah well that's a lot of the customers
that go they love being slapped yeah
there's so many weird bars here that you
can pay for which would you like to be
slapped by a muscle girl or is that not
really your thing probably not I mean
you should try
you pay for money for it right it feels
like I've done something wrong if I got
slapped normally but if I pay money
tickets transaction I did not pay money
for it though
so it felt good because it's free still
though it was I was like I'm getting a
steal and I'm getting content but the
slapping part was the worst part of the
whole transaction cost like is it like
10 bucks a slash I think it was 30 bucks
30 bucks for a slap you think it was 18
of them yeah I just gave you like 600
smackers yeah yeah well nearly let me
just uh yeah yeah that's that's a large
value for money that's what that's what
I thought when I was getting beaten up I
was like this is great value dying on
the floor you're like yo I'm getting my
money's this is great it's got like 600
bucks I can't say I don't like a deal
though better than the designer clothing
it's just like actually I don't get paid
in money anymore uh just uh pay me in
slaps that's that's my currency there
was like a part of me for a brief second
that got it until I got slapped a second
time and I was like get it anymore and I
was like this is just her but for the
first slap I was like I see I see what
this is yeah
I kind of got the appeal of you just a
woman just hitting you I was like I was
like I kind of got it for a brief second
until it actually started hurting and I
was like no more no more of this stuff
stop yeah yeah I think you guys also
enjoy the slapping no I'm good
I definitely have a little bit of
masochistic traits there's a part of me
that does like get it like a little you
know when you get everyone does secretly
yeah just not he's like now different
levels right yeah
yeah you wanna you wanna try a little
bit no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no I don't
know no I can't Jay will do it wait
actually it's a hate crime if I do it he
can do it
I don't know three guys here I know
you're the best
I have rings on so I'm gonna hurt him
take the Rings off oh my God okay you
don't slowly take them off I don't want
to slap you it's not hard you're not I
can't hold back it's not possible I'm
competitive
I'd go for the kill I can't can party
from bleed
I'd slap you full pound go if that was
only 10.
yeah yeah I pronounce things wrong on
purpose okay okay yeah yeah I know but
uh yeah there's a lot of weird Services
you can get here in Japan
um I don't get this part taken in them
outside so he's got it outside of work
he has a wife which one did you enjoy
the most of the weird none of them none
of them which one like did you dislike
the least like oh that's good you know
if you had to do one right again and
you're like I'm gonna not hate this one
dislike the leash okay so there's two
um out of everything my wife has uh
forced me to do this this is gonna sound
so bad right because okay either either
option is bad but the one I dislike the
least out of everything she's forced me
to do is probably getting whipped
you like the pain because the pain is
not bad you know what he was because
okay okay
I have a weird question did your wife do
it to you or did your she make someone
else do it she made someone else do it
to me that's crazy
okay did she watch yeah she was uh she
was
my wife covers a lot of like weird bars
so she I was she was like pick a bar
that we're gonna film a video in
together yeah so so yeah
what I thought was the most
family-friendly sounding bar it was a
steampunk bar I was like Grace steampunk
I love steampunk I've seen Arcane you
know famous with their whipping yeah
formative Alchemist I was like what's
the worst thing that could happen at
this bar and uh so there were a few like
punishment uh punishment games that you
could pay for at this bar and now I
thought there were just gonna be a very
very strong drink or something so the
first punishment was labeled milk right
so I was like oh it's just it's just
gonna be like
um like a gallon of milk challenge you
drink yeah yeah it's just gonna be like
uh like they Spike some milk with
alcohol or something uh yeah I thought
it was going to be it does sound kind of
gross yeah yeah but it was like a
punishment that I was like okay I I I'll
do it for the content it was an
alcoholic milk uh so the first thing
they did was
um they get they go to the back room and
the first thing they emerge out with is
um is a bib and a baby bottle
I'm like where is this going right now
okay and uh so they get you to uh go on
your knees and they put the bib on you
and they you and then you have to make
baby noises
your wife made you go today
I filmed it we know who wears the pants
in the relationship
I'm so sorry
it's okay it's okay I feel I feel that
baby
and then and then they uh feed you
through the baby bottle and uh that was
one of the most embarrassing experiences
honestly between that and getting
whipped I'd get whipped too yeah that
just sounds absolutely great
oh my God the craziest thing is your
wife wanted you to do this yeah my uh
she paid for it yeah she paid for it my
wife paid for it yeah um well you know
just watched you do it did she get kick
out I mean I mean okay so when she she
did a punishment uh as well which was
wasn't as bad as mine it was like they I
I feel like she knew what she was doing
she was like you can get the milk one
that sounds like uh that sounds like the
table yeah that doesn't sound too big
yeah meanwhile she was like she got a
fake interrogation with uh and then you
know she was she was in like a fake
interrogation and the bomb but the bar
Maids were like faking like a really
really harsh interrogation and then they
had like a syringe full of alcohol that
which they like you know kind of like
forced her to drink that was that was
easy that almost sounds like exciting
yeah exactly yeah exactly compared to
the stranger
strange
babe in the the noise is yeah weird yeah
yeah that's that's what you can look
forward to and yeah next time you're in
Japan next time you're in Japan yeah so
if you were to recommend me a strange
experience it'd be the whipping okay
honestly honestly
oh whatever whatever you're into
whatever you're into I don't think I'm
into anything but like I don't know I
just don't know until you try yeah if
you have the purest mind and we could
really just taint that so yeah just yeah
uh
um
uh no no I haven't I've I uh I worked in
a strip club here for a while you worked
in it well for like an hour or two you
stripped it uh yeah not very well I
think I didn't make a lot of money oh my
God it's on YouTube you can watch it
it's is that that's allowed on YouTube a
lot of it isn't so I blurred a lot of it
yeah okay yeah it's uh they were nice it
was good fun time wow okay all right now
tell me your crazy story um he's dressed
up as a baby gotten whipped uh he's been
a stripper have you have you seen violet
evergarden yeah um no but the music's
amazing in that yeah you know about it
though right yeah I know the job so I
watched uh a porn star dressed up as
Violet from Violet evergard and get DP'd
and I and I put it on YouTube
what like in live no it's not on the
video no it's not all no I mean like you
were there in the room I was there I
made eye contact with a that is so
strange yeah that's a thing
you just what you just paid money and
just walked in Oh no I got it for free
no no no no no no no no no no no no so I
did it I did like a a behind the scenes
of a porn star with your followers
though if you want to it should be fine
yeah sure no I was just shocked that
that's a thing
obviously yeah well yeah but I mean like
I just you just turned off so I heard
you're doing my question for you is
where did you did you come up with this
idea you talk to your team and you're
like guys I really want to see this
happen no no
we have a we have a mutual friend uh who
used to be a Japanese porn star and She
Got Me The Roots yeah
and she was like are you interested I
was more wondering if it was your idea
I'm gonna go look for it I'm getting my
team on it they're gonna find him
right now evergarden's my favorite
that it no longer became my favorite
show yeah I can imagine yeah I I you
guys are crazy
once you realize as soon as you get in
contact with one of these bars or one of
these like weird places a lot of them
know each other so a lot of them will
recommend you to go to other places well
because they're really really well
connected so you want to make a good
impression because if you can make a
good impression with one that just kind
of opens the door for literally anything
this this country is just a treasure
Trove of content yeah
very sorry for tainting your innocent
mind I feel very very bad right now I
mean I'll probably never see this stuff
I guess yeah unless you want us yeah I
mean I don't even think I'd be able to
find it if I well I haven't even been
able to get around for the most part
I've always been like hey can you help
me get around like when I came here
um I got march to just be I was like
March call the call the thing and I'll
just get in and they'll drop me off
right he's like yeah I can do that and I
was like okay gotten lost on the train
system a couple times yep
um
yeah that's the whole thing and I
haven't gotten on it you'll be a pro
next time it goes the opposite direction
yet yeah so that that's good I still do
that yeah a lot of times I have gone to
like the wrong Tunnel right right if
that makes sense yeah sometimes yeah
that can happen yeah yeah well I'm sure
next time they have much more luck yeah
thank you thanks so much
fun thanks guys also yeah
um I mean obviously go check out
psychuna stuff links in the description
and uh hey look at all these patrons you
see all these pictures
and it's on the screen right now yeah oh
but if you did you would it's more
Patron well yeah there's a patron right
on the screen right now they're all
they're all there yeah look at them all
someone you like yeah
maybe maybe we'll take you to one of the
bars and put that behind the paperwork
okay
he sounds exciting I'll do it if Connor
does it why do I have to go I'll just
feel more comfortable
this guy's already crazy guy will
pretend to be a baby I won't feel as
awesome getting slapped by eating buff
women isn't crazy anymore okay well he
was just standing there taking it yeah
you wanted something it was like it was
like a JoJo fight for me I was like
I was just being a good husband actually
yeah
but hey you feel like you didn't want to
be there yeah he didn't want to just had
to yeah would you go again
but uh hey if you'd like to support the
show then go up to our patreon
patreon.com trash taste also follow us
on Twitter send us some memes on the
subreddit and if I hit our face listen
to us on Spotify yeah and uh yeah we'll
see you guys next week yeah trash day
[Music]
good